ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO EXPLAIN
THE PROCESSES THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE OUR
CENTRAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC. FOR THOSE OF YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THIS PROCESS WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE WHILE
I GO THROUGH IT AGAIN FOR THOSE
TUNING IN FOR THE FIRST TIME.
LET ME COVER SOME OF THE
TECHNICAL SIDE OF THINGS FOR
THE DAY IN RESPONSE TO THE CODE
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING
AND WE'VE MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. CONDUCTING
THE HEARING IN A WAY THAT
PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND THE
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OF OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT. THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND IT
WILL BE RIGHT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE FOUR ONE
EIGHT FIVE. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. SEVEN FOUR NINE SEVEN NINE
EIGHT SEVEN. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN
YOUR LAN. AND AT THAT TIME YOU
MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID FEEDBACK YOU HAVE TO MEET
THE DEVICE THAT YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. AND THAT IS SO WE CAN
HEAR YOU IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU WHEN WE SO. WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AS WE DO THIS. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING ARE CERTAIN MEETING
SERVICE EXCUSE ME. OUR HAVE
THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS AND IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. OR MAYBE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW ONLINE
TOOL SO PLEASE BE PATIENT SO
EVERYBODY CAN BE HEARD. AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF OUR COURT
REPORTER. I WILL ASK ALL
SPEAKERS COLLEAGUES IN
WITNESSES ALIKE TO SPEAK SLOWLY
AND CLEARLY AND- IF I NEED TO
INTERRUPT FOLKS ARE HAVE YOU
SLOW DOWN- PLEASE FORGIVE ME. I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO GET YOUR TESTIMONY. AND
THAT OUR COURT REPORTER AINA IS
ABLE TO DO THAT. SO BEFORE WE
BEGIN THE AGENDA TODAY WE NEED
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM I SHOULD
LET FOLKS KNOW THAT- SENATOR
GROVE IS ABSENT TODAY US
SENATOR COM LOGGER IS
PRESENTING A BILL ELSEWHERE
RIGHT NOW. I ALSO KNOW THAT MY
VICE CHAIR HAS TO LEAVE TO GO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM ELSEWHERE
WILL BE BACK SO YOU WILL SEE
SOME MOVING PARTS TODAY. BUT
WE'VE DONE THIS BEFORE AND- WE
WILL KEEP EVERYTHING MOVING BUT
YOU MAY SEE PEOPLE COME AND GO
AND IT'S ONLY BECAUSE- SOME OF
US ARE DOING DOUBLE DUTY. IN
OTHER COMMITTEES TODAY SO WITH
THAT OP MADAM SECRETARY WOULD
YOU PLEASE ESTABLISH A CORPSMAN
CALL THE ROLL. GROVE KAMLAGER
LAYERED HERE LAYERED HERE FAITH.
HERE BATES HERE ATKINS HERE
ATKINS HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM SO
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO DO IS GO
AHEAD AND- IF THERE ARE NO
OBJECTIONS. ARE GO AHEAD AND
TAKE UP- FIRST ON TODAY'S
AGENDA GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES
NOT REQUIRED TO APPEAR AND THAT
WOULD BE ITEMS TO G. THROUGH J.
AND THAT WOULD INCLUDE-
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR MEMBERS ON
THE COMMISSION ON DISABILITY
ACCESS AND ONE MEMBER FOR THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY CONSERVATION
AND DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION
ASSUMING I CAN TAKE THOSE
TOGETHER COLLEAGUES. ARE WOULD
MOVE ALL FOUR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR LAYERED- MADAM
SECRETARY WILL YOU CALL THE
ROLL. ROATH KAMLAGER LAYERED ON
LAYARD I'D FAITH ALL RIGHT IF I
ATKINS AYE ATKINS AYE AND WE
WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN SO THAT
WHEN SENATOR COM LONGER GETS
HERE SHE CAN ADD ON I WOULD
ALSO TAKE A MOTION ON BILL
REFERRALS ITEM NUMBER THREE. I
WOULD SO MOVE THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED UP MADAM SECRETARY WE
CALL THE ROLL- KAMLAGER LAYERED
HI THERE I BATES BATES AYE
ATKINS HI AT INSIDE AND WE WILL
ALSO LEAVE THAT OPEN SO THAT
MISS COM LONGER SENATOR COM
LONGER CAN ADD ON. SO I WILL
NOW MOVE TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR
AND THAT WOULD BE ITEMS OUT ONE
A THROUGH C. AND THIS IS FOR
MEMBERS OF THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION. BUT I SEE ALL OF OUR
OUR CONFEREES ON TODAY LET ME
JUST THANK YOU IN ADVANCE FOR
YOUR PATIENCE ALREADY I SO MUCH
APPRECIATE. IT FROM EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU WE ARE GOING TO
START WITH THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION MEMBERS THAT WOULD BE
DR CYNTHIA GLOVER WOODS. MISTER
JAMES J. MCCLELLAN MCCLELLAN
PLEASE FORGIVE ME AND OF COURSE
IDA RODRIGUEZ AND SO LET ME
WELCOME EVERYONE. OUT WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO DO IS TAKE UP
INTRODUCTIONS IN THE ORDER.
THAT I STATED YOUR NAME A
BEGINNING WITH- DOCTOR GLOVER
WOODS. AT AND THEN- PROCEED ON
WANTED TO TIME AFTER EACH OF
YOU'VE GIVEN YOUR INTRODUCTIONS
IN YOUR OPENING COMMENTS.
OBVIOUSLY FEEL FREE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE THAT MIGHT
BE WITH YOUR THAT YOU WANT TO
RECOGNIZE OPENING COMMENTS AND
THEN WE'LL MOVE RIGHT TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. AND
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND START WITH
DOCTOR GLOVER WOODS OUT WELCOME
DR- GO AHEAD INTRODUCE YOURSELF
AND ANYONE YOU WOULD LIKE TO
WITH YOU OPENING COMMENTS AND
WE'LL GO FROM HERE. WELCOME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON. I'M GETTING A LITTLE
BIT OF A BACKGROUND. LET'S SEE
HOW IT GOES GO AHEAD AND TALK
FOR A MINUTE WE'LL GET A SENSE
AND GO FROM THERE. OKAY WHAT
WE'RE GETTING THAT I'D LIKE
KNOWLEDGE THAT. ONE OKAY WE
DON'T WE ARE GETTING A LITTLE
FEEDBACK LET ME GET SOME ADVICE
FROM STAFF TO SEE. OUR WHAT YOU
THINK. SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
ISSUES THAT WE CAN HELP WITH
BEFORE WE- GET GOING. WELL JUST
MAKE SURE EVERYTHING IS OFF
HERE THAT SHOULD BE OFF.
IT
TAKES DR GO HEAD START AGAIN ON
THE SEE IF THAT'S BETTER. OKAY
GOOD AFTERNOON. I THINK IT IS A
LITTLE BETTER THANK YOU. YEAH I
AM ASSEMBLY A CLEVER WAY TO AND
I DO WANT TO SHARE THAT JOINING
ME VIRTUALLY AND BURY HIS
FRIENDS I IS MY HUSBAND AS WELL
AS MY MOTHER AND OTHER MEMBERS
OF MY FAMILY EVEN THOUGH
THEY'RE NOT HERE ON CAMERA WITH
ME BUT I DO WANT TO SHARE WITH
YOU WHAT ON A PRIVILEGE IT IS
TO BE ABLE FOR ALL OF YOU THIS
AFTERNOON. AS A DAUGHTER OF A
PROUD MEMBER OF THE UNITED
STATES MARINE CORPS AT A HIGH
SCHOOL ENGLISH TEACHER I
REFLECT UPON MY LIFE AND IS A
PRODUCT OF OUR CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM. AND I HAD
IN MY REFLECTION I REALLY
REFLECT ON WATCHING MY MOTHER I
TEACHER WHO WAS TEACHING HIGH
SCHOOL ENGLISH ALSO AN ADVISER
FOR VARIOUS EXTRACURRICULAR
ACTIVITIES AND HOW SHE WOULD
AFTER A DAY OF WORK COME HOME
GRADE PAPERS AND EXAMS ARE THAT
OUR STUDENTS HAVE COMPLETED ALL
WHILE TAKING CARE OF HER
FAMILY. SHUTTLING US BACK AND
FORTH TO ACTIVITIES AS WELL AS
COOKING DINNER AND I HAVE TO
TELL YOU WHEN WATCHING HER DO
THAT DAY IN AND DAY OUT I CAME
TO THE CONCLUSION THAT I
DEFINITELY DID NOT WANT TO BE A
TEACHER AND DID NOT WANT TOGO
INTO THE FIELD OF EDUCATION. IT
WAS JUST ARE AMAZING TO ME TO
GOING TO A PROFESSION THAT
REQUIRES SO MUCH INSIDE AND
OUTSIDE OF WORK AND THAT ALSO
HAD HEARING DEGREES OF RESPECT
FROM MEMBERS OF THE SOCIETY SO
I DECIDED I WAS GOING INTO
COMPUTER SCIENCE BECAUSE THAT.
WAS THE WAY OF THE FUTURE.
THERE THAT TIME. WHILE I WAS-
PURSUING MY TO. I JUST TO WORK
AS AN- SAYS- ANY HIGH IN LONG
BEACH. AND I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK WITH STUDENTS THAT WERE
IN ENGLISH AS A SECOND LANGUAGE
CLASSES. AS WELL AS SEVENTH IN
IN EIGHTH GRADERS WHO WERE
REALLY TRYING TO ACQUIRE
LITERACY SKILLS THAT ALIGN TO
THE GRACE THAT THEY WORK IN.
AND IT WAS AT THAT TIME. THAT I
UNDERSTOOD WHY MY MOTHER IN
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF OTHER
TEACHERS DID THE WORK THAT THEY
DID. I HAVE TO TELL YOU TO
WATCH STUDENTS GROW IN LEARN
STILL LEAVES ME WITHOUT WORDS.
EVEN AFTER OVER THIRTY YEARS.
IN THIS PARTICULAR PROFESSION.
SO I DECIDED I WAS GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND I WAS GOING TO BE A
TEACHER. AND OVER THIRTY YEARS
FROM THAT DECISION HERE I AM
BEFORE YOU TODAY. I HAVE HAD
THE PRIVILEGE TO SERVE STUDENTS
IN MANY DIFFERENT ROLES AS A
TEACHER A SCHOOL PRINCIPAL AND
DISTRICT ADMINISTRATOR AND ALSO
COUNTY OFFICE ADMINISTRATOR. IN
EACH POSITION THAT I'VE HELD AT
NOW IS AN APPOINTEE TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION. MY MISSION IS AND
ALWAYS HAS BEEN TO ENSURE THAT
EVERY STUDENT THAT ENTERS OUR
SCHOOLS AS THE GUIDANCE AND
SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED. TO
ACHIEVE WHATEVER IT IS THAT
THEY DESIRE WHEN THEY GRADUATE
FROM OUR HIGH SCHOOLS. AS A
MOTHER AND AS A WIFE OF A
RETIRED LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
I KNOW FIRST HAND HOW DAILY
EXPERIENCES IN SCHOOL CAN
IMPACT FAMILY LIFE. AND I TRULY
BELIEVE THAT ALL PARENTS AND
GUARDIANS WANT WHAT'S BEST FOR
THEIR CHILDREN EVEN IF THEY MAY
NOT KNOW EXACTLY HOW TO GO
ABOUT. MAKING SURE THAT HAPPENS.
ONE THING I DO KNOW IS THAT THE
STUDENTS IN OUR GREAT STATE ARE
VERY DIVERSE GROUP. SOMEONE
HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE
ECONOMICALLY WEALTHY AND SOME
DO NOT. SOME WOMEN IN
ENVIRONMENTS THAT ARE FUNDING
AND LACKING AND SOME DO NOT
SOME OF THE LAST SCHOOL AND
WANT TO COME TO SCHOOL EVERY
DAY AND WOULD COME ON THE
WEEKENDS IF THEY COULD. AND
SOME DO NOT. SO ARE WORKING
PUBLIC EDUCATION IS MORE THAN
JUST PROVIDING STUDENTS WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCEED. IT'S
ABOUT ENSURING THAT ALL
STUDENTS HAVE THE SCAFFOLDS IN
THE SUPPORT THEY NEED IN ORDER
TO SEIZE THOSE OPPORTUNITIES.
SO MY COMMITMENTS TO CALIFORNIA
TO THE STUDENTS FAMILIES AND-
EDUCATORS IS TO WORK HARD AND
DILIGENTLY TO BE SURE THAT OUR
PRACTICES IN OUR POLICIES AND
PUBLIC EDUCATION HELP TO BUILD
SCALPELS. AND NOT TEAR THEM
DOWN OR EVEN WORSE CREATE
BARRIERS TO REACHING THEM. SO I
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR INVITING ME
TO BE BEFORE YOU TODAY I LOOK
FORWARD TO MY TIME WITH YOU
THIS AFTERNOON TO RESPOND TO
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DR GLOVER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL
TURN NOW TO MR MCQUILLAN AND
LET YOU INTRODUCE YOURSELF-
ANYONE YOU WOULD LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE GO AHEAD AND WELCOME.
THANK YOU. I'M HONORED TO BE
WITH ALL OF YOU TODAY IN THIS
CONFIRMATION PROCESS. I'M JIM
MCQUILLAN. I'VE BEEN MARRIED TO
CHRISTINE MCQUILLEN FOR THIRTY
PLUS YEARS NOW AND I BELIEVE
SHE'S IN THE NEXT ROOM WATCHING.
CHRIS'S LOVE MY LIFE AND- THE
MAJOR PILLAR IN MY SYSTEM. I
MEAN YOU TRY SILVA SOON AS I
REASON IN THE NORTH IN DON'T
CAL AMONGST THE PA RAY. THE
BEAUTIFUL RIVER AND THE COASTAL
AREA OF FR NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
ALONG THE OREGON BORDER. I AM
THE PROUD FATHER OF SIX GROWN
CHILDREN. WALL ATTENDED PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA. TO OUR
CSU GRADUATES ONE IS A UC
BERKELEY GRADUATE AND TO OUR
CTA HEAVY EQUIPMENT OPERATORS
AND I HAVE ONE SON WHO'S A
DISABLED YOUNG MAN. I NOW HAVE
NINE GRANDCHILDREN WHO ALL
ATTEND PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA OR FOR THE ONES WHO
ARE SCHOOL AGE THAT IS. MY
EDUCATION WAS ALL IN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS I HAVE A MASTER'S
DEGREE IN PSYCHOLOGY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY AT
SACRAMENTO. I HOLD A PPS
COUNSELING CREDENTIAL IN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS A
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY LICENSE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. MY
CAREER HAS SPANNED FOR MORTAR
MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS NOW I'VE
BEEN IN PRIVATE PRACTICE I'VE
BEEN A LECTURER AT HUMBOLDT
STATE UNIVERSITY. COLLEGE OF
THE REDWOODS I'VE BEEN AN
ASSISTANT PRINCIPAL AS WELL AS
A COUNSELOR IN THE SCHOOLS.
I'VE ALSO WORKED FOR COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS SERVING OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS FOR MORE THAN
THIRTY YEARS NOW. I CURRENTLY
WORK AND I OVERSEE A LARGE
EDUCATION DEPARTMENT FOR
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST INDIGENOUS
TRIBE THE YUROK TRIBE. OUR
PROGRAM OVERSEAS ECD
PROGRAMMES- COLLEGE AND CAREER
READINESS PROGRAMS. CHILDCARE
PROGRAMS AND A WORLD CLASS
YUROK LANGUAGE PROGRAM THAT IS
OFFERED IN FOUR OF THE MAJOR
HIGH SCHOOLS UP IN THIS AREA.
IN THAT LANGUAGE PROGRAM IS
ARTICULATED TO MEET THE CSU AND
UC ENTRANCE REQUIREMENTS FOR
CALIFORNIA. I BELIEVE EDUCATION
IS A PATHWAY OUT OF POVERTY.
THE ROAD TO EMPOWERMENT ANY WAY
TO FIND A PRODUCTIVE
CONTRIBUTING ROLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY ALL THROUGH EDUCATION.
I HAVE VOLUNTEEREDTO BE ON THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION. I
BELIEVE I WOULD MAKE A UNIQUE
REPRESENTATIVE ON THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION.
REPRESENTING TRIBAL INDIGENOUS
STUDENTS THE RURAL COMMUNITIES
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS
WELL AS ALL THE OTHER SIX POINT
TWO MILLION STUDENTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND I WE WILL NOW
TURN TO MISS RODRIGUEZ TO SAY
WELCOME TO YOU AND OPENING
COMMENTS AND ANYONE YOU'D LIKE
TO RECOGNIZE WELCOME. THANK YOU
SO MUCH OUR SENATOR ATKINS GOOD
AFTERNOON VICE CHAIR OF BATES
AND ALONE AGAINST SENATOR
LAYERED- IT IS AN ABSOLUTE
HONOR TO BE WITH YOU HERE TODAY.
AND I'LL I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
QUESTIONS- WATCHING NOT I HERE
IN THE HOUSE BUT LIVE ELSEWHERE
AROUND CALIFORNIA. ARE MY
BROTHERS ON THE HANDLE AND WE
ARE OF THE YES MY CURRENT
COLLEAGUES AND FRIENDS AND
TREMENDOUS SUPPORT GROUP MISS
ROBIN NABILA I WOULD HAVE BEEN
A GLENDALE AND A NOW GROWN
THIS. AND ALSO A FORMER
COLLEAGUE OF MINE. WHO WAS ONE
OF THE CO FOUNDERS OF- A. R. AN
URBAN COLLEGE PREP SCHOOL IN
EAST PALO ALTO AND ALSO- WE
SERVED ALONGSIDE EACH OTHER ON
THE COMMISSION FOR TEACHER
CREDENTIALING BODY SOUL THE
LOCAL LEVEL THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE. FOR YOUR
UNCONDITIONAL SUPPORT ALWAYS
AND I WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL
OF THOSE WHO ARE SUBMITTED
LETTERS ON MY EHALF IN SUPPORT
OF MY CONFIRMATION. IT MEANS A
LOT TO ME. I'M SO GRATEFUL TO
GOV NEWS FOR THIS. TO THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION AND FOR HIS
CONFIDENCE IN ME TO SERVE AT
THIS LEVEL. I FEEL THAT ALL
THAT I HAVE LEARNED AND
ACCOMPLISHED BOTH AS AN
EDUCATOR AND AS A POLICY MAKER
HAS BROUGHT ME BEFORE YOU TODAY.
I'VE BEEN A CLASSROOM TEACHER
FOR TWENTY THREE YEARS I'M
CURRENTLY IN THE CLASSROOM. AT
CENTRAL UNION HIGH SCHOOL IN EL
CENTRO CALIFORNIA. UP TO
FIFTEEN MINUTES FROM THE
MEXICAN BORDER- AND I HAVE BEEN
A CLASSROOM TEACHER FOR TWENTY
THREE YEARS AND A NATIONAL
BOARD CERTIFIED TEACHER FOR
SIXTEEN OF THOSE YEARS. MY
BACKGROUND IN EDUCATION IS
INCREDIBLY DIVERSE I'VE TAUGHT
AT DIFFERENT LEVELS DIFFERENT
SUBJECTS- AND BUT I ALWAYS SAY
THAT. THE MOST IMPORTANT- THING
THAT I TEACHERS STUDENTS ARE
BRIGHT REGARDLESS OF THE
SUBJECT I'VE SERVED ON VARIOUS
COMMISSIONS AND BOARDS. ALWAYS
WITH THE AIM OF SUPPORTING OUR
STUDENTS AND WORKING TO CREATE
EQUITABLE LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REPRESENT THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE AND PURCELL. AS AN
INTERNATIONAL LEADER IN
EDUCATION R. AS AN AMBASSADOR
IN EDUCATION AND IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN GOVERNOR
BROWN APPOINTED ME TO SERVE ON
THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING. SERMON ON THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION ARE
FEELS LIKE A NATURAL
PROGRESSION AFTER HAVING SERVED
FOR SIX YEARS ON THE CTC. WHERE
I CHAIRED THE EDUCATOR
PREPARATION COMMITTEE AND
SERVES AS LIAISON TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ACCREDITATION.
DURING MY TENURE WITH THE CTC
REMAKE GREAT STRIDES WE UPDATED
THE ACCREDITATION SYSTEM-
UPDATED TEACHING STANDARDS AND
VERY OLD ALL WITH THE GOAL OF
CREATING MORE REFLECTIVE
PRACTITIONERS. WHO ARE PREPARED
TO MEET THE SOCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL. AND ECONOMIC
ACADEMIC NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS
TODAY. I GREATLY APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT SO THAT I CAN
BRING ALL OF THIS EXPERIENCE MY
PROXIMITY TO STUDENTS FAMILIES
AND TEACHERS TO THE STATE
BOARD. ARE WE'RE WE CAN
CONTINUE TO BUILD EQUITABLE
SYSTEMS WHERE OUR TEACHERS AND
STUDENTS AND COMMUNITIES WILL
THRIVE THANK YOU. MS RODRIGUEZ
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN
THANK EACH OF YOU FOR YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS LET THE RECORD
REFLECT THAT- SENATOR CALM
WATER HAS JOINED US I ALREADY
LET THEM KNOW SENATOR THAT YOU
HAD TO PRESENT AT A DIFFERENT
COMMITTEE- WITH THAT I'M GOING
TO START SENATOR LAYERED WITH
YOU. IF YOU'RE PREPARED TO ASK
COMMENTS AND I WILL LET YOU
DIRECT YOUR QUESTIONS TO
INDIVIDUALS ARE TO EACH ARE AND
LET YOU TAKE IT FROM THERE OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND- LET ME THANK ALL THREE.
ARE OF PEOPLE IN FRONT OF US
TODAY FOR A MEETING WITH ME
YESTERDAY I THOUGHT OF WAS A
VERY GOOD MEETING AND WE TALKED
ABOUT. ON MANY THINGS AND
MOTIVATIONS AND HOW OF AL JUST
BOARD FITS ARE IT IN THE
EDUCATION GOVERNMENTS AND I
DON'T FEEL THE NEED TO GO OVER
THAT AND EACH OF YOU I ASKED
EACH OF YOU WHAT MOTIVATED YOU
A. N. I THOUGHT I WOULD SORT OF
FOLLOW UP WATER JUST ASKING FOR
PEOPLE TO EXPAND ON THAT FOR
EXAMPLE- MISTER MCCLELLAN.
TALKED ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE
TRIBAL ACHIEVEMENT GAP WAS IN
EDUCATION WAS HIS PERSONAL
MOTIVATION AND THAT IT REALLY
DROVE HIM AND I WAS WONDERING-
MISTER MCCLELLAN IF YOU COULD
EXPAND ON THAT. THANK YOU
SENATOR. I CAN'T REMEMBER WHAT
I SAID BUT- WHAT NO NO YOU JUST
HAVE TO BE CONSISTENT WITH WHAT
YOU. RIGHT WELL THERE ARE
SEVERAL THINGS THAT MOTIVATE ME
TO BE IN THIS POSITION ARE TO
BE HONORED IN THIS POSITION
LIKE MANY OF US- I WANT TO
SERVE BETTER MY COMMUNITY FOR
SURE- YOU KNOW I'M AMERICAN
INDIAN FROM THE FAR NORTH HERE
THE YUROK TRIBE. ON MY MOTHER'S
SIDE THERE CONTINUES TO BE AN
ACHIEVEMENT GAP WITH THEM THIS
POPULATION THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IN TERMS OF
GRADUATION RATES OR TEST SCORES
AND IN OTHER AREAS MOVING ON TO
HIGHER EDUCATION. I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE- OUR PROGRAMS OUR
EFFORTS TOGETHER. MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN REDUCING THIS
ACHIEVEMENT GAP YOU KNOW AND
THAT MOTIVATES ME AND IS ALWAYS
MOTIVATED ME TO IMPROVE MY
COMMUNITY. AND HELP MY FAMILY.
HELP THE NEXT GENERATION TO BE
MORE SUCCESSFUL I WAS A FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENT IN
MY FAMILY THE FIRST. TO GO THAT
WAY WAS A VERY LONELY
EXPERIENCE AND NOBODY CAME TO
MY GRADUATION AT SACRAMENTO
STATE AND I. I STILL HAVE PAIN
OVER THAT YOU KNOW IT WAS IT
WAS NEW AND DIFFERENT YOU KNOW-
BUT NOW I AM HAPPY TO SAY SOME
OF MY YOUNGER SIBLINGS HAVE NOW
GRADUATED COLLEGE. OF AN NIECE
THAT JUST FINISHED UP THE WHOLE
STATE ON FRIDAY I GOT TO BE A
PART OF CELEBRATING HER OF
OTHER NIECES HAVE WHO HAVE
COMPLETED. AND IT'S A NEW IT'S
A NEW TIME AND- I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE US- MAKE OUR CLASSROOMS
MORE ACCOMMODATING AND-
ACCEPTING- FOR AMERICAN INDIAN
STUDENTS- THEY NEED TO SEE.
THEMSELVES IN THE CURRICULUM
THEY NEED TO SEE THEMSELVES OF
ROLE MODELS IN THE STAFF AND
TEACHING WE HAVE A SHORTAGE OF
TEACHERS ALL THROUGHOUT. THE
SPECIALLY AMERICAN INDIAN
TEACHERS. I WOULD LIKE TO. MAKE
A DIFFERENCE SO. WHEN WE SEE
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES COMING
WHETHER THEY BE BILLS OR A
LEGISLATION COMING THAT MAY.
MAKE OUR CLASSROOMS MORE
INCLUSIVE. AND HELP IN THOSE
WAYS I HOPE WE CAN ALL WORK
TOGETHER. TO CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS AND THINK THAT.
ONE OF THE IMPORTANT THINGS
ABOUT A BOARD LIKE THIS IS
PEOPLE BRING THEIR OWN
EXPERIENCE INTO THE BROADER
RANGE IN A WAY THAT. WE CAN
MAKE SURE TAT THAT OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM INCLUDED IN
REFLECTS IT SO I PER SHARE
COMMENTS. WELL LET ME ASK MS
RODRIGUEZ- WHEN I ASKED YOU THE
A SIMILAR QUESTION. ARM YOU
MENTIONED THAT YOU STARTED OUT
AS A LITERACY VOLUNTEER IN
THERE FOR THE STATE LITERACY
PLAN AND WHAT IT LED TO IN THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM MEANT A LOT TO
YOU I WONDER IF YOU COULD TALK
A LITTLE ABOUT THAT. ABSOLUTELY
OUR- THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION SO WHEN IT WHEN I
STARTED AS A LITERACY VOLUNTEER
I WAS ACTUALLY ON MY WAY TO LAW
SCHOOL. OUR I WAS I WAS MORE
INTERESTED IN WORKING AS A
VOLUNTEER TO TEACH READING
BECAUSE READING THE SOMETHING
THAT HAS ALWAYS BEEN- VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME AND I KNOW THAT
IT'S ESSENTIAL FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
TO HAVE NOT ONLY ACCESS TO
TAXED BUT TO BE ABLE TO
DECONSTRUCT AND TO BE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT AND AS I
MENTIONED YESTERDAY- IT'S ONLY
BY. BY READING AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE HAVE
ACCESS TO OUR DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS AND SO I REALLY
EMPHASIZE THIS IN MY IN MY
CLASSES TODAY AND I BELIEVE
THAT OUR BUILDING LITERACY FROM
A YOUNG AGE BUILDING
UNDERSTANDING. IS OUR ONE OF
THE IT BUT THE MOST FUNDAMENTAL
SKILL THAT OUR STUDENTS CAN
DEVELOP AND THAT WE CAN BUILD
ON THAT SO A FEW MONTHS AGO-
WHEN WE APPROVED THE STATE
LITERACY PLAN- I WAS VER
EXCITED- YOU KNOW NOW THERE ARE
THERE OPPORTUNITIES FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ALLEY AIMS TO. I'VE
COME UP WITH OUR- BRANDS-
THAT'LL THAT'LL COME THROUGH US
AND YOU WILL BE ABLE TO IMPROVE.
THEIR LITERACY SKILLS IN THE
READING SKILLS OF OUR STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU-
PROJECT THAT ANSWER VERY MUCH
AND WHAT IT MEANS ALSO TO WHAT
YOU BRING. BOB TO THE BOARD AND
THEN LET ME ASK OF MS GLOVER
WOODS. ARM YOU KNOW AND MAYBE
THE OTHERS WANT TO COMMENT ON
THIS I ASKED ALL THREE OF YOU.
ARE YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON THE
FACT THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE YOUR
PERSONAL INTEREST IN SOME WAY
OR YOUR PERSONAL BACKGROUND.
AND YOU MIGHT BE CALL IT IN
YOUR CASE ARE WORKING WITH A
LOCAL- EDUCATION AGENCY. AND
YOU MIGHT BE CHALLENGED IN A
WAY. THAT YOU FEEL LIKE YOU
HAVE TO VOTE AGAINST THE OUR
INTEREST OF THAT AGENCY IN
SOMETHING YOU DO ON THE STATE
BOARD AND YOU. YOU TALKED ABOUT
REPRESENTING THE PERSPECTIVE OF
ALL THE STUDENTS ANDTHAT THAT
MIGHT. YOU KNOW NAVIGATE YOU IN
THAT CONFLICT I WONDERED IF YOU
COULD. EXPAND ON THAT A LITTLE.
YES I CAN'T I AS I WAS SHARING
WITH YOU ON YESTERDAY ONE THING
I DO REALIZE THAT AS A MEMBER
OF THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION. WE HAVE A- A MORAL
OBLIGATION TO REPRESENT TO MAKE
DECISIONS FOR ALL STUDENTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
WHILE I BELIEVE THAT ANY
DECISION THAT COMES BEFORE THE
BOARD AND IT DECISION THAT
NEEDS TO BE MADE IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT I WOULD APPROVE
IT WAS DETRIMENTAL TO STUDENTS.
THERE MIGHT BE SOMETHING THAT
PERHAPS MAY NOT NECESSARILY. BE
ORDER ONLINE IN OUR LOCAL AREA
BUT MIGHT BE BEST FOR THE GROUP
BOTH OUR DIVERSE GROUPS OF
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA AS A
WHOLE- AS A SHARED WITH YOU ON
OUR CONVERSATION YESTERDAY I
HAVE NOT HAD THAT. COME FORWARD
AS OF YET- I DO BELIEVE IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND WE HAVE
OUR FINGER ON THE PULSE OF
REALLY HOW TO ENSURE THAT ALL
STUDENTS HAVE EQUITABLE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS AND- WANT
TO BE SURE THAT WE HAVE
POLICIES AND PRACTICES THAT
SUPPORT THAT. BUT I DO REALIZE
THAT- BEING IN THIS PARTICULAR
C. AS ONE OF GREAT
RESPONSIBILITY AND ONE THAT
REQUIRES REPRESENTATION FOR NOT
JUST MY LOCAL AREA BUT FOR OUR
STATE AS A WHOLE. THANK YOU I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSE
AND MADAM CHAIR. BOB PRITCHARD
ALL THREE RESPONSES I CONSUMERS
FEEL GOOD ABOUT ALL THREE
CANDIDATES THANK YOU. CENTER
CLERT THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M
GOING TO TURN TO A MADAM VICE
CHAIR NOW FOR HER COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU AND- THANK
YOU FOR STEPPING UP FOR WHAT I
BELIEVE IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT ASSIGNMENTS. AS A
VOLUNTEER AND WE KNOW THAT THIS
IS TRULY A VOLUNTEER JOB AT
THAT TIME- ONLY BRINGS THE MOST
PASSIONATE. OF FOLKS FORWARD-
TO PUT THEIR NAME IN THE HOPPER
AND HOPEFULLY GETTING APPOINTED
TO SOMETHING BECAUSE YOU'RE IN
CHARGE OF OUR FUTURE
GENERATIONS. AND HEARING OFF
FROM YOU AND I GOOD JOB AND
COLLEAGUES TO MY RIGHT HERE-
AND WHAT MOTIVATED YOU ALL I
DID HAVE A CHANCE TO MEET WITH
YOU AND I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT
BUT YESTERDAY WAS A VERY LONG
MEETING ON THE PANDEMIC
COMMITTEE. I AND WE HAD SOME
REALLY INTERESTING COMMENTS
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED TO OUR
CHILDREN. ARE DURING THE
PANDEMIC YESTERDAY AT REALLY
FOCUSED ON THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY BUT PREVIOUSLY LOOKING
OUT OF THE ON THE IMPACTS THAT
WE'VE HAD TO EDUCATION HAS BEEN
CERTAINLY. ONE OF THOSE TOPICS
SO YOU'VE BEEN ON THE FRONT
LINES OF THAT ALL OF YOU AND-
WE DO APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR-
DEDICATION YOUR DEVOTION AND
WHAT I FEEL CAME THROUGH IN.
YOUR INTERVIEWS THAT YOU HAVE
JUST A LOVE AN ABSOLUTE LOVE
FOR THE PROFESSION THAT YOU ARE
IN AND THAT MEANS SO MUCH.
CERTAINLY TO ALL OF US AS
PARENTS GRANDPARENTS AND
CERTAINLY TO OUR CHILDREN- I
WAS THINKING ABOUT HAVING ONE
OF YOU ARE ALL OF YOU AS A
TEACHER. AND MY CAREER PATH
WOULD HAVE BEEN A JOY BECAUSE
WE REMEMBER THOSE TEACHERS WHO
MADE SUCH A DIFFERENCE WITH US.
AND YOU COME ACROSS WITH ALL
YOU KNOW HAVING THAT KIND OF
FUN COMMITTEE ON JOB LOVE FOR
WHAT YOU DO AND CERTAINLY FOR
THOSE YOU SERVE. I AM JUST TWO
QUESTIONS AND I'M GOING TO PUT
IT TO ALL THREE OF YOU. ARE
BECAUSE THEY'RE ON OUR MIND AND
ONE HALF TO DO- THE CONCERNS
THAT OF ARE RAISED IN THE DRAFT
TWENTY TWO CALIBER. MATH FOR. I
KNOW THAT COMING BEFORE. A ONE
OF DODD COMMITTEES. HONDA I
GUESS IF THE CONCERN IS THAT
XCELERATED MATHIS CERTAINLY IS
NOT FOR EVERYONE AND CERTAINLY
IT WASN'T FOR ME HI FIND THAT
WASN'T MY STRONG SUIT. I MADE
IT THROUGH THAT I'M HOPING THAT
WE'RE NOT LOOKING AT SOMETHING
THAT MIGHT ENCOURAGE ALL
STUDENTS TO STRIVE FOR MORE AND
I THINK OF SPECIALLY ARE YOUNG
WOMEN. WE HAVE STEM AND THAT
HAS ENCOURAGED SO MANY TO GET
INVOLVED IN FACT THERE'S SO
MANY JUST AN ORANGE COUNTY-
YOUNG WOMEN WHO'VE ENTERED THE
ENGINEERING PROFESSION AND
CERTAINLY BEEN INCREASE ALONG
THERE ON EDUCATION PATH TO DO
THAT. SO I GUESS FOR WHAT I'D
LIKE TO ASK. ALL THE THREE OF
YOU OR INDIVIDUALLY TO RESPOND
TO WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE
LOOKING FOR IN TERMS OF THE
FINAL PROPOSAL THAT WILL COME
BEFORE YOU LATER THIS YEAR FOR
ADOPTION THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
CONTROVERSY OVER THE YEARS
MEMBER THE NEW MATH AND- WITH
OUR KIDS COULD GET ON BOARD
WITH THAT AND- HOPEFULLY WE'RE
NOT TAKING ANOTHER TURNED OUT
TO AYE CATCHES. KIDS KIND OF IN
THE MIDDLE OF REALLY GRASPING
THE ON MATH AT PRESENT THAT
THIS ISN'T SOMETHING THAT'LL
GIVE THEM A LEFT TURN ON AS
THEY YOU KNOW GO FORWARD SO ON
SHARE SOME OF YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THAT WITH OFF. THANK YOU LET ME
START WITH YOU DR GLOVER WOODS
AND THEN WILL MOVE TO MISTER
MCCLELLAN AND THEN. MISS
RODRIGUEZ SO GO AHEAD DOCTOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- TO ANSWER
THE QUESTION I WOULD SAY THAT
ONE OF THE- KEY THINGS THAT WE
WILL BE LOOKING. FORWARD AND
LOOKING AT WHEN THE DOCUMENT
COMES FORWARD TO THE STATE
BOARD. IS TO BE SURE THAT IT IS
A DOCUMENT THAT PROVIDES THE
GUIDANCE. THAT'S NEEDED FOR
STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF WHERE
THEY MAY BE AND MATH PASSED.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THEIR
DESIRES MAYBE AROUND
MATHEMATICS THAT THEY'RE ABLE
TO BE. SUCCESSFUL AS I SHARED
WITH YOU IN MY OPENING
STATEMENT WE HAVE A VERY
DIVERSE GROUP OF STUDENTS. THAT
ARE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND FOR OUR STUDENTS THERE ARE.
HIGH ACHIEVERS IN THE AREA OF
MATHEMATICS WHO WANT TO ACHIEVE
AND CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD.
IN THAT PARTICULAR SUBJECT AREA
WE WANT TO BE SURE ABOUT THE
DOCUMENT THE FRAMEWORK THE
MATHEMATICS FRAMEWORK SUPPORTS
THOSE STUDENTS. IN ACHIEVING
THOSE HIGHER ASPIRATIONS IN THE
AREA OF MATHEMATICS WE ALSO
WANT TO BE SURE FOR STUDENTS
THAT MIGHT BE STRUGGLING WITH
MATH. THAT THERE ARE THERE'S
GUIDANCE IN THAT DOCUMENT FOR
THE EDUCATORS THAT WILL BE
WORKING WITH THEM. TO BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THEM AS WELL SO WHEN
I THINK ABOUT WHAT. WOULD COME
FORWARD AFTER THE ERROR RATIONS
ARE. WORKING WITH THE
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY
COMMISSION AND ALL OF THE
PUBLIC COMMENTS THAT WE WILL
RECEIVE ON THE DOCUMENT. I'M
LOOKING FOR A KITE THAT IS
GOING TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT.
ALL STUDENTS. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK FOR THAT.
THANK YOU MR ARE MISTER MCCALL.
YES THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION.
THAT PROCESS- WITH MATHEMATICS
IS CURRENTLY UNFOLDING IN. CAN
YOU HEAR ME OK. OKAY YES WE
CAN'T. N. IT IS EARLIEST THIS
WEEK THE INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY-
COMMITTEE IS MEETING- TO TAKE
COMMUNITY IMPORTANT WRITTEN
INPUT SO THAT PROCESS- AND
AGAIN WE HAVE TO REMEMBER- IT'S
A FRAMEWORK OF MATHEMATICS AND
FRAMEWORKS ARE OUR GUIDES
THEY'RE NOT MANDATED IN THE
PROCESS THEY'RE NOT MANDATED
FOR DISTRICTS TO TEACH FROM- WE
WANT THIS PROCESS TO PLAY OUT
HIM AND WIN THAT RECOMMENDED
FRAMEWORK REACHES US AT THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION THEN
WILL TAKE A GOOD LOOK AT IT.
AND- AND DECIDE THEN WHETHER TO
APPROVE IT OR NOT YOU KNOW THE
FRAMEWORK- IS GUIDES FOR LOCAL
DISTRICTS- IN THOSE DISTRICTS
MAKE DECISIONS ON WHAT IS
OFFERED FOR THEIR DISTRICT
THERE LOCALLY- YOU KNOW I WOULD
WANT CHILDREN TO HAVE OPTIONS
STILL WITH THE HIGH LEVEL MATH
AS WELL AS C. D. E. AND CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION MATHEMATICS
AND- THOSE KIND OF OPTIONS AND-
I WOULD HOPE THAT THE DISTRICT
WOULD HAVE THAT FLEXIBILITY FOR
THOSE VARIOUS PATHWAYS. YOU
KNOW WHETHER IT'S A STUDENT ON
THEIR WAY TO THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA OR STUDENTS WHO
NEEDS MATHEMATICS TO BE ABLE TO
BE A PLUMBER OR A BUILDER- WE
WHAT WE WANT TO HAVE OPTIONS IN
THESE PATHWAYS FOR ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS. AND OF COURSE WE
DON'T WANT TO SEE SOME OF THOSE
HIGHER LEVEL MATHS ELIMINATED I
KNOW THERE'S SOME
MISINFORMATION CIRCULATING
ABOUT ELIMINATING CALCULUS FOR
SOME OF THESE HIGH LEVEL MATHS
WE NEED TO. KEEP THOSE OPTIONS
AVAILABLE FOR OUR STUDENTS.
THANK YOU FOR MENTIONING OUT
BECAUSE I THINK THAT MIGHT BE
WHERE THE CONTROVERSY IS KIND
OF THE MERCHANT MAYBE. A LITTLE
BIT A LITTLE TIDBITS GETTING IN
THE MEDIA ON THAT I COULDN'T
IMAGINE THAT THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT WASN'T PART OF
IT. NOT NOT NECESSARILY
MANDATED SO IT. YES THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THAT QUESTION AND I
WILL- WHAT REPEAT EVERYTHING
THAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY
SAT. UP I AGREE WITH THEM AND I
WILL JUST ADD THAT. WHEN I
STARTED TEACHING IN ABIT ON
BECAUSE I'M A SOCIAL STUDIES
ENGLISH AND SPANISH TEACHER AT
THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL BUT WHEN
I STARTED TEACHING AB ONE OF
THE- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
DISCOVERED IS THAT A LOT OF MY
STUDENTS. REGARDLESS OF THEIR
GRADE LEVEL IN HIGH SCHOOL
STRUGGLING WITH MATH. AND SO I
THOUGHT WELL HOW CAN I HELP
WITH IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME
SINCE I'VE HAD A HIGH SCHOOL
MATH R. SO I STARTED A BOOK.
OUT WITH THAT WITH PROFESSOR
JAVELIN WHO'S A MATHEMATICS
PROFESSOR AT STANFORD. LATER HE
AND I BECAME VERY GOOD FRIENDS
AND I LEARNED A LOT. FROM HIM
ABOUT MATHEMATICAL THINKING AND
MATHEMATICAL CONCEPTS AND THE
DIFFERENT WAYS THAT WE CAN
ENCOURAGE OUR STUDENTS- YOU
MATHEMATICALLY TO. PROBLEMS HOW
TO OUT THE MOVE IN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT AREAS IN THEIR LIFE.
AND STILL. SOME OF OUR
STUDENTS- YOU KNOW WILL TAKE UP
PERHAPS. MAY REQUIRE LESS MATH
I THINK YOU KNOW WE ALL CERTAIN
CAREERS- WHETHER YOU ARE EIGHT
HOUSE FRAME BURKE OR- A DOCTOR
ARE RIGHT YOU KNOW THERE'S%
CERTAIN. CERTAIN TYPES OF
MATTHEW USED FOR CERTAIN
CAREERS AND AT THAT POINT
THAT'S WHERE WE NEED TO
DIFFERENTIATE US AT SCHOOLS AND
THIS IS A LOCAL DECISION. AGAIN
WITH THIS FRAMEWORK THAT'S UP
FOR DISCUSSION. ARE WE AS
TEACHERS NEED TO DIFFERENTIATE
WHAT MATH OUR STUDENTS NEED FOR
THE CAREERS OF THEIR INTERESTED
IN WITHOUT HOLDING ANYBODY.
WITHOUT YOU KNOW- WHICH IS ONE
OF. THE ONE OF THE MYTHS ABOUT-
THIS. IS THAT YOU KNOW. HELP IS
GOING TO BE GONE AND PEOPLE
WON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THAT NO
NOT AT ALL OF THESE PEOPLE WE
NEED STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
FOR ENGINEERING JOBS FOR JOBS
AND AEROSPACE INDUSTRY AND A
LOT OF THOSE REQUIRE A STRONG
MATHEMATICAL BACKGROUND. RIGHT
WHETHER OR ENGINEERING OF. MOB
MEMBER MCCLELLAN MENTIONED- C.
T. AND THOSE PATHWAYS DOES ALSO
REQUIRE CERTAIN TYPE OF MATH
JOKES ARE IT'S THIS IS A VERY
INTERESTING DISCUSSION AND-
I'M- LOOKING FORWARD TO- YOU
KNOW WHEN THIS PROCESS IS OVER
HAVING. A FRAMEWORK- IN FRONT
OF US AT YES YOU ARE. STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE ANSWERS I'M
I'M SO IMPRESSED WITH ALL THREE
OF YOU I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT I WILL BE SUPPORTING YUR
CONFIRMATION NOT. I BROUGHT UP
THE MATH QUESTION BECAUSE IT IS
SOMETHING THAT COMES SIDE TO
US. AS PARENTS GRANDPARENTS AND
LEGISLATORS YOU KNOW IT IT IS
SO PROBABLY THE THING THAT MUCH
MAYBE. NEXT TO READING OR MAYBE
ACTUALLY IN FRONT OF READING AS
CREATES MOST CONSTERNATION ARE
FOR PARENTS AS THEIR CHILDREN
STRUGGLE WITH EITHER OF THOSE
SUBJECTS AND- GIVEN YOUR- ALL
THREE OF YOU YOUR INVOLVEMENT
IN YOUR PASSION FOR YOUR
STUDENTS OF. I THINK WE'LL SEE
ARE PROBABLY A GREAT PRODUCT
THAT COMES OUT OF THAT ARE WILL
BE FOLLOWING IT AND THEN- ANY
THOUGHTS YOU HAVE THAT YOU WANT
TO SHARE WITH ME PREVIOUS. TO
THAT- SUBSEQUENT TO THAT THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL BECAUSE I'M
GETTING SOME OF THIS FOR MY
DAUGHTER BY THE WAY AND HER
KIDS SO. ANYWAY THANKS AGAIN
AND DAUGHTER I'M VERY IMPRESSED
WITH. ALL OF YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE AND YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THE FAR THIS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT UP COMPONENT OF.
OUR ON OUR HUMAN AREBEING. OF
HUMAN. LEARNING THE FROM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM VICE
CHAIR OF. THERE'S NOTHING LIKE
GETTING IT DIRECT FROM THE KIDS
IN THE- WITH THE YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO ARE GOING THROUGH IT AND
THEIR PARENTS WHO ARE TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THEY ARE. FOLLOWING
AND LEARNING. RIGHT ABSOLUTELY.
SENATOR KAMLAGER THANK YOU
MADAM PRO TEM UM AND- VERY
HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY- I JUST
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS I DO
WANNA AND ECHO THE SENTIMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR BATES-
I AM A PARENT WHO HAS LIVED
THROUGH DISTANCE LEARNING FOR
OVER A YEAR- AND IT IS A
MIRACLE- DATA I AM STILL IN MY
RIGHT MIND. I AM OUT TIPPING MY
HATS OFF TO ALL THE OTHER
PARENTS- AND THE TEACHERS OUT
THERE WHO HAVE HAD TO MANAGE
THEIR WAY THROUGH THIS- IT HAS
REALLY ON EARTH- A LOT OF
DISTRESSING THINGS- ABOUT THE
KIND OF. STRESSORS THAT WE
PLACE ON OUR SYSTEMS ABOUT HOW
SOME OF THE SYSTEMS WERE NOT-
YOU KNOW ADEQUATELY RESOURCE
AND HOW WE'VE REALLY BEEN
DENYING- SOME REALITIES SOME
VERY REAL. AND STARK REALITIES
ABOUT HOW OUR CHILDREN ARE
LEARNING IN THE PRESSURES ARE
PUTTING ON OUR PARENTS- AND THE
SCHOOL SYSTEMS. SO I HAVE TWO
QUESTIONS AND I WOULD LIKE TO
DIRECT THE FIRST ONE JUST IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME TO- DR
GLOVER WORDS. IT'S REALLY ABOUT
ON THE STATE OF AFFAIRS WITH
REGARDS TO OUR SUPERINTENDENTS.
I CROSSED THE STATE THERE ARE A
LARGE NUMBER OF THEM WHO ARE
RESIGNING WHILE WE'VE HAD IT
HAPPEN IN SAN FRANCISCO. WE'RE
HAVING IT HAPPEN IN LOS
ANGELES- WE'RE SEEING IT IN
CULVER CITY I MEAN I AM
REPRESENT THREE CITIES AND TWO
OF MY CITIES OF SUPERINTENDENTS
THAT ARE LOSING LEAVING- AND
THEN ACROSS THE COUNTRY WE ARE
SEEING THIS PHENOMENON. AS WELL
AND SO JUST WANTED YOUR THOUGHT
SINCE PART OF- THE WORK THAT
YOU ALL DO IS ABOUT THIS SORT
OF REGULATING THE GOVERNANCE-
YOUR THOUGHTS ON IF- THE
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE THAT WE
HAVE IN PLACE- WITH FOR OUR
SCHOOL SYSTEMS IF IT'S WORKING-
OR YOU KNOW IS IT UNTENABLE.
BECAUSE I DO THINK THAT. WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO CREATE
SOME SYSTEMS THAT WILL ALLOW
FOR STABILITY- IN TERMS OF
HAVING SUPERINTENDENTS COMING
IN AND BEING ABLE TO DO THE
WORK THAT THEY NEED TO DO IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THEIR-
DISTRICT BOARD MEMBERS- TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICE WHICH IS
EDUCATION TO OUR STUDENTS. AND
FAMILIES BUT I'M WONDERING IF
WE HAVE JUST. PRESSURIZED THIS
SO MUCH- THAT THE YOU KNOW THE
YIELD IS NOT WHAT WE WANT AND
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT. THANK
YOU SENATOR FOR THAT QUESTION
AND I WILL SAY FIRST AND AS A
MOM WHO ALSO. HAD A DAUGHTER ON
DISTANCE LEARNING OVER THIS
LAST YEAR AND IT'S DEFINITELY
BEEN QUITE AN INTERESTING RIDE-
SERVING FROM BOTH ENDS AS A MOM
AND ALSO AS AN EDUCATOR- TO
YOUR QUESTION ABOUT THE
GOVERNANCE AND THE- SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF. THAT MINISTRY-
SUPERINTENDENTS THAT ARE
RESIGNING I WILL SAY THAT I DO
BELIEVE OUR GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE WHILE IT'S NOT- I
WILL SAY NOT NECESSARILY UNDER
THE PURVIEW OF THE STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION ARE BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE LOCAL CONTROL. THERE ARE
ON THOSE OPPORTUNITIES AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL FOR SUPERINTENDENT
CAN BE ABLE TO WORK IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
GOVERNING BOARDS THAT ARE
ELECTED IN THEIR AREA AND SERVE
THE NEEDS OF THEIR COMMUNITIES-
OF MIGHT I DO THINK THAT THIS
LAST- FIFTEEN SIXTEEN MONTHS
IT'S BEEN ONE THAT. THE
VOCABULARY WORDS BEEN
UNPRECEDENTED IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE NEVER SEEN AND OUR
PARTICULAR LIFETIME AND I
BELIEVE THAT THE QUICK NEED TO
RESPOND AND IN SHORT AND GIVE
IT TO ENSURE THAT STUDENTS GOT
EVERYTHING THAT THEY COULD.
DURING. THIS TIME- INSTRUCTION
CHANGING IN AND TO REMOTE
INSTRUCTION- REQUIRED A LOT OF
TIME QUITE A LOT ACTUALLY AND
TO THE POINT I BELIEVE I HEARD
YOU MAKE ARE THERE WERE.
SUPERINTENDENT DISTRICT
ADMINISTRATORS PRINCIPALS
TEACHERS PARA PROFESSIONALS
THAT PUT IN AN INORDINATE
AMOUNT OF TIME TO TRY TO BE
SURE STUDENTS COP WITHIN ME. SO
AS FAR AS IS THERE A NEED TO
LOOK AT OUR GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE IS THERE ANY TO
CHANGE ANYTHING IN THE
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE I THINK
IT'S SOMETHING FOR CONTINUAL
REFLECTION OR WE SERVE IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT. OF CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT AND WHILE THERE ARE
THINGS THAT WORK WELL THERE I'M
SURE THINGS THAT CAN BE DONE
BETTER. TO NOT ONLY SUPPORT
THOSE WHO ARE SERVING IN THE
ROLE OF THE ADMINISTRATION AND
SUPERINTENDENT BUT TO SUPPORT
EVERYBODY THAT'S IN THE SYSTEM
AND I THINK WE HAVE A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY- AS STUDENTS RETURN
TO IN PERSON INSTRUCTION IN THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO SCHOOL
YEAR. TO LOOK AT WHAT THOSE
AREAS ARE THAT WE CAN LEARN
FROM WHAT THOSE AREAS ARE THAT
WE CAN BUILD ON AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY WHAT MIGHT BE SOME
AREAS THAT WE CAN LOOK AT. AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL TWO AND JUST TO
ENSURE THAT THE ENVIRONMENT IS
ONE THAT IS SUPPORTED AND
CONDUCIVE. FOR ALL THAT ARE IN
OUR SYSTEM. THANK YOU FOR THE-
CREDIBLY THOUGHT. ON I
APPRECIATE. YOUR RESPONSE. AND
MY LAST QUESTION I'LL DIRECT
TO- MISTER AT MCCLELLAN. YOU I
TALKED A LOT ABOUT- THE WELL
NOT A LOT BUT YOU DID REFERENCE
THE DASHBOARD AND- SORT OF HOW
WE CAN BE MORE ACCOUNTABLE AND
WOULD LOVE FOR YOU TO EXPAND
ON- YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
STRUCTURE OF ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE. YOU
KNOW- THE LEGISLATURE- WITH
THE- HELP OF THE GREAT- DR
WEBBER REALLY FOUGHT FOR- L.
CFF FUNDING- AND- YOU KNOW WE
HAVE EL CAP- AND ALL OF THESE
PLANS. AND PLANS AND PLANS AND
THEN IT SEEMS AS IF- WE'RE
VEERING OFF COURSE YOU KNOW
THE- FOR LC FF. IT'S NOT BEING
USED AS IT WAS INTENDED. AND
THEN WE'RE BEGINNING TO SEE
SOME CHALLENGES WITH SORT OF
THE APPLICATION- YOU KNOW OF
THESE PLANS ACROSS THE STATE SO
JUST- WANTED TO GET YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THE STRUCTURE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT WE HAVE IN
PLACE AND- IF THERE ARE EFFORTS
ARE AREAS ARE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR. IMPROVEMENT ARE FINE
TUNING BECAUSE I THINK AT THE
END OF THE DAY- YOU KNOW WE
WILL ALL BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE-
TO WHETHER OR NOT WE HAVE. A
DEVELOPED AND SUPPORTED AND
SUSTAINED A SYSTEM. DESIGNED TO
EDUCATE OUR YOUNG PEOPLE- AND
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE STRESS
THAT COMES WITH THAT FOR THEIR
FAMILIES AND SO- WOULD LOVE TO
KNOW YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT.
MMHM THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION.
WELL THE PANDEMIC HAS ADDED A
NEW LAYER OF- GETTING THROUGH-
TO THIS ACCOUNTABILITY PROCESS
I KNOW THAT THEN WE'VE ALL BEEN.
GETTING THROUGH THAT HOPEFULLY
TOGETHER YOU KNOW THE STRESS
THE MENTAL HEALTH BUT WE CAME
TO MY MIND WITH THE QUESTION
YOU ASKED BEFORE WITH OUR TO
PERTINENT CHAU CHECKING IN WITH
OUR STUDENTS CHECKING IN WITH
OUR TEACHERS. AND OUR
SUPERINTENDENT THAT'S ABOUT
THEIR WELLNESS. AND THE
PRESSURE AND STRESS THEY'VE ALL
BEEN UNDER YOU KNOW THAT'S WHY
YOU NEED TO SAY THAT FIRST BUT
THE ACCOUNTABILITY YOU KNOW IN
OUR ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM I'VE
BEEN. A PART OF THE PROCESS OF
BEER IN THE NORTH WITH THE L.
CAP PROCESS ANDI'M I'M PROUD
OF OUR RURAL DISTRICTS UP HERE
IN TERMS OF THEIR- EFFORT TO
REACH OUT TO THE COMMUNITY
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. IN A LOT MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS MOST OF IT IS
REMOTELY IN TRYING TO GET
INPUT. ON THEIR PLANNING
PROCESS SEVERAL OF THE
DISTRICT'S APPEAR IN DIFFERENT
SPACES IN NETWORK PLANNING
PROCESS OF THE L. KAPLAN.
THEY'VE DONE A OF- EVEN THROUGH
THE CLOUDINESS OF HE PANDEMIC
OF A GOOD JOB IN REACHING OUT
AND TRYING TO GET INPUT ON
THEIR PLANNING PROCESS. AND
THEN- TURNING AROUND YOU KNOW
MID YEAR AND SAYING LOOKING
BACK HOW HOW ARE WE DOING WITH
OUR PREVIOUS PLANNING PROCESS
AND I KNOW THAT'S BUILT INTO
THE L. CAP. PROCESS AND I'VE
BEEN PROUD OF OUR RURAL
DISTRICTS ARE FOR MAKING THAT
EFFORT ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING
THE TIMES WE'RE IN NOW. IN
TERMS OF ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
PLANS THAT THEY ARE
IMPLEMENTING AND THEN
ACCOUNTABLE TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS
IN THOSE PLANS- AND ALL THE
LOCAL YOU KNOW IT'S A LOCAL.
EFFORT YOU KNOW THAT'S BUILT
INTO THE NAME- L. C. F. F. THE
HOME OF THE GETTING THE LOCAL
VOICE CERTAIN LOCAL PERSPECTIVE
FROM PARENTS- STUDENTS AND ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AND I'VE BEEN ONE
WHO WERE WAS ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE TABLE NOT TOO PLEASED IN
THE PROCESS JUST A FEW YEARS
BACK- BUT I HAVE TO SAY I'M- A
MUCH MORE. HAPPIER WITH WHAT
I'M SEEING ESPECIALLY IN THE
CLOUDINESS OF THE PANDEMIC AND-
AND HOW DIFFICULT. IT HAS BEEN-
FOR EVERYONE TO ME YOU KNOW A
TICKET OTHER IN IN PERSON.
ALTHOUGH MANY OF OUR RURAL
DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN IN PERSON
YOU KNOW AND HAVE BEEN IN
PERSON UP HERE FOR SOME TIME
WITH THE CHILDREN COMING IN TWO
DAYS A WEEK. AND THIS IS THE
MONTH TO CELEBRATE OUR TEACHERS
AND- WE- WHAT WAS SAID IN THE
OPENING I THINK IS HUGELY
IMPORTANT WE ALL HAD A TEACHER
THAT MADE THE DIFFERENCE IN OUR
LIVES. IT IS THE MONTH TO
CELEBRATE OUR TEACHERS TO HONOR
THEM. WELL THE WAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT- AND I CAN
SEE YOUR- YOUR PASSION YOUR
THOUGHTFULNESS ON THIS ISSUE
AND HOW YOU ARE YOU'RE PROBABLY
THINKING OF SOME VERY SPECIFIC
PEOPLE AS YOU WERE RESPONDING
TO THAT QUESTION I COULD FEEL
THAT AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
IT- YOU KNOW I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE APPOINTMENTS
HERE TODAY- FOR THIS BOARD- AND
I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE YOU ALL
TO FIND YOUR POWER- BECAUSE
WHILE. THERE IS LOCAL AND THE
WORD LOCAL CONTROL I THINK WE
ALL HAVE A COLLECTIVE MANDATE-
TO ADDRESS THE INEQUITIES THAT
ARE IN OUR THAT OUR IN OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM AS WE SEE MORE
PRIVATE SCHOOLS AND OTHER
SCHOOLS THAT ARE OPENING AND
HAVING KIDS COME IN. AND THEN
THESE CONTINUES CONVERSATIONS
AROUND- NOT HAVING ACCESS TO
BROADBAND NOT HAVING THE RIGHT
KIND OF RESOURCES NOT HAVING
THE RIGHT KIND OF MENTAL
SUPPORT FOR- OUR SCHOOLS IN OUR
RURAL COMMUNITIES IN OUR URBAN
COMMUNITIES AND OUR POOR
COMMUNITIES YOU KNOW IT IS
REALLY INCUMBENT UPON ALL OF US
TO WORK TOGETHER IN A
COLLECTIVE EFFORT TO ADDRESS
THOSE INEQUITIES. IN WE CANNOT
JUST. WISH THEM AWAY WITH GREAT
BUDGETS- BECAUSE AT THE END OF
THE DAY IN YEARS PRIOR IN
YEARS. FUTURE YEARS WE WILL SEE
THE RESULTS OF THAT KIND OF-
DISREGARD- WITH STUDENTS WHO WE
HAVE FAILED AND SO I. YOU ARE
DOING- YEOMAN'S WORK HERE I
HAVE TO SAY AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO STEP UP TO
THE CHARGE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR COM LOGGER- INCREDIBLY.
THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSION AND
DIALOGUE- IN YOUR COMMENTS AND
CERTAINLY FROM MY COLLEAGUES- I
WILL ADD TO- TO WHAT THEY'VE
ALREADY SAID. MY APPRECIATION
IN PARTICULAR FOR YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS- A CLEARLY WHAT
MOTIVATES EACH OF YOU- AND YOUR
DESIRE TO SERVE- AND THE
DIVERSE PERSPECTIVES AND
EXPERIENCES THAT YOU BRING TO
THE TABLE OUT WAS REALLY
REFLECTED IN. THE FEW QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
BUT I ALSO HAVE TO TELL YOU I
REALLY APPRECIATED READING YOUR
RESPONSES TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE AND THROUGH THE
PROCESS- YOUR SERVICE- I
COULDN'T AGREE MORE WITH MY
VICE CHAIR MADAM VICE CHAIR.
YOUR SERVICE IS SO APPRECIATED
OBVIOUSLY ON TOP OF EACH JOB
YOU HAVE. PERSONALLY YOU KNOW
THIS IS A WHOLE DIFFERENT. OUR
JOB THAT REQUIRES A LOT OF
THOUGHT ATTENTION- THANK
GOODNESS YOU HAVE THE
EXPERIENCE- ARE. YOU BUT BEHIND
YOU AND WITH YOU- TO TACKLE
THIS SO I- I APPRECIATE ALL
THAT I'VE HEARD WE'RE GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND GO TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC- TO HEAR FROM THEM.
AND WITH THAT- I WILL REMIND
FOLKS BEFORE WE GO TO PUBLIC
MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE TO SPEAK
WE WERE WE WILL START IN
SUPPORT. BUT A REMINDER FOR
WITNESSES THAT ARE GOING TO
WISH TO PROVIDE COMMENT VIA
PHONE THAT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AGAIN IS ON THE
SCREEN ON THE WEBSITE IT'S.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN FOUR NINE
SEVEN NINE EIGHT SEVEN. AND
WITH THAT I'M GONNA START WITH
PUBLIC COMMENT RIGHT HERE IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. AND
IF THERE AREMEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
ABOUT THESE CONFEREES IN
SUPPORT. OF I WILL TAKE THOSE
COMMENTS NOW. AND FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE TO
SPEAK. ARM I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION IF ANY. N.
ARE VERY BRIEF COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT WE WILL GET TO
OPPOSITION IN A MINUTE WE ARE
ON SUPPORT MAY MA'AM WELCOME
AND DOT GO AHEAD. SENATOR THANK
YOU MY NAME IS JOHANNA FINNEY.
AND I REPRESENT- CALIFORNIANS-
WHO DESIRE A TRANSPARENT
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND THE
ABILITY TO DO PUBLIC SPEAKING
IN FRONT OF- ARE LEGISLATORS-
SO I THINK YOU FOR THAT
OPPORTUNITY AND I THINK YOU- TO
THE APPOINTEES FOR PRESENTING
THEMSELVES- SO OPENLY. AND IF I
MAY CAN POINT OF ORDER AM I
ABLE TO ASK A QUESTION OF THEM
OR JUST THE PURPORTED COMMENT
YOU YOU ARE AND YOU ARE NOT THE
COMMITTEE WILL ASK THE
QUESTIONS A YOUNG DODD YOU CAN
SPEAK. AND THIS IS IN SUPPORT
SO IF YOU WANT TO GET HIDDEN IN
SUPPORT OF. ANY INDIVIDUAL
MEMBER BEFORE US OR
COLLECTIVELY AS THAT'S WHAT IS
EXPECTED VERY GOOD- AND SO I
HEARD TODAY- FROM THE- MS
RODRIGUEZ ABOUT DEMOCRACY AND
HOW THAT WAS IMPORTANT- IN-
REPRESENTING. THIS STATE AND-
THE EDUCATORS AND THE STUDENTS
I MYSELF- WAS BORN AND RAISED
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. AND IT WAS
SCHOOLED AT SAC CITY I THAT
ALLOWED ME AFTER TWO YEARS
THERE TO GO. TO A UC SYSTEM. SO
I AM. REALLY VALUE THAT UPPER.
AND SUPPORT- AT THE MISTER
RODRIGUEZ IN HER STATEMENT
ABOUT DEMOCRACY I JUST WANTED
TO. STATE THAT I HOPE SHE KNOWS
THAT- DURING THIS COBIT TIME WE
WERE UNABLE TO- REALLY LIKE I
NEED TO I NEED TO STOP YOU KNOW
ARE YOU SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF-
IT YET IT'S NOT COMMENTARY SO I
NEED YOU TO GET THEIR STATE
YOUR SUPPORT. OKAY OKAY YES SO
I'M FOR DEMOCRACY SOUNDS LIKE-
MISS RODRIGUEZ IS AS WELL- I
HEARD MR MCQUILLAN US SPEAK
ABOUT LOCAL- I THOUGHT ALREADY
AND- ALLOWING PEOPLE TO HAVE
ACCESS BASED ON THEIR NEEDS. IN
THEIR COMMUNITY AND THEIR RURAL
AREAS AND- I TO AND THE FOLKS
WHO ARE FIGHTING TELECOM
ORDINANCES AND STATE RULINGS
ABOUT THAT- ARE FOR LOCAL
CONTROL AS WELL. AND WHEN IS
CLOVER WITH ITS I AM IN SUPPORT
OF YOU AS WELL- I HEARD GOOD
THINGS FROM YOU TOO-
PARTICULARLY THE ISSUE AS THE
SENATOR SPOKE TODAY ABOUT THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE AND THE NEED
FOR- FOLKS TO- HAVE ACCESS
EQUALLY- WIRED BROADBAND IS THE
WAY TO GO AND I WOULD SUPPORT
YOU EVEN MORE IF THE THREE OF
YOU WOULD INVESTIGATE THAT FOR
YOUR LOCALITIES FOR THE SCHOOLS
FOR THE STUDENTS- THERE'S A LOT
OF DAMAGE THAT CAN BE DONE WITH
THE INUNDATION OF A LOT OF
WIRELESS. SO THANK YOU I
SUPPORT OFF THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR- COMMENT IN SUPPORT I
NEXT IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE SIR ARE YOU COMING FORWARD
THANK YOU IF. WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON. CENTER ATKINS IN
MEMBERS MARKRAM. ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS. IN FAVOR OF HARD
WIRED INTERNET ACCESS IN
AGAINST THE USE OF WIFI IN THE
CLASSROOM. I I'VE- I WANNA MAKE
TWO BASIC POINTS AND- IF
THERE'S A QUESTION PERHAPS
THOSE MEMBERS COULD ASK THE
APPOINTEES THIS PART. OF THE
FIRST IS THAT- HUH CCORDING TO
AND THERE'S AN AWFUL LOT OF
RESEARCH OUT THERE THAT LONG
TERM EXPOSURE TO THE RADIATION
THAT COMES FROM WIFI AS- COVER
THAT ON THAT ITEM IS REALLY NOT
BEFORE US IF YOU'RE HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO THE- CONFEREES BEFORE AS YOU
CAN SPEAK TO THAT WE ARE NOT
DISCUSSING POLICY ISSUES SO IF
YOU'RE- OKAY. PLEASE LIMIT
YOUR- COMMENTS TO THAT IF YOU
WOULD SIR THANK OKAY WELL TO
THE EXTENT THAT THE APPOINTEES
A WILL SUPPORT A POLICY OF HARD
WIRED INTERNET ACCESS ICE ICE.
IN FAVOR OF THEIR APPOINTMENTS
AND THE OTHER THING IS- THE
SENATOR. COLOGUARD I CAN
PRONOUNCE HER NAME WHO
MENTIONED- ACCESS THAT THERE
ARE SOME STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
THEY LACK ACCESS TO BROADBAND.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
APPOINTEES- I UNDERSTAND THAT
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE IS NOT
PRIMARILY A TECHNOLOGICAL ISSUE
AS PRIMARILY A FINANCIAL ISSUE.
WHICH HAS OF THE FINANCIAL
SOLUTION I SUPPORT THEM AS WELL
SENATE WOULD LOVE TO HEAR THE
COMMENTS ON THAT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK GOODNESS MONEY
I'M SURE THEY WILL TAKE THAT TO
HEART. I IN TERMS OF THE
COMMENTS THAT YOU MADE SIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
THAT IS IN SUPPORT. OKAY THANK
YOU. AND SEEING- I NEED TO ALSO
LOOK AT ROOM ONE TWELVE A WE
HAVE A SECOND ROOM- AS
INDICATED EARLIER. I DO NOT SEE
ANYONE APPROACHING THE PODIUM
SO I WILL GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE AND- THIS IS FOR
HER SUPPORT. OUR MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD INTRODUCE YOURSELF
AND PROP THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT WE
WILL BEGIN WELCOME. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. COMMAND
AGAIN ONE ZERO. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR IN AS WE WAIT FOR
THEM TO QUEUE UP I WILL SAY TWO
WITNESSES IN THE QUEUE WE ASK
THAT WHEN YOU SPEAK TO PROVIDE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION IF ANY
AND POSITION ON THE APPOINTMENT
WE ARE ON SUPPORT AT THE MOMENT
AND AGAIN ON BEHALF OF OUR
COURT REPORTER. SPEAK SLOWLY
AND CLEARLY MISTER MODERATOR
THANK YOU BACK TO YOU. BLIND
SEVENTY TWO YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM PROGRAMS
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JEFF
BACA REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS DR ED ONE GOMEZ IN
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR CYNTHIA
COOPER WOULD. HAVE YOU HEARD
TODAY DR GLOVER WOODS HAS BEEN
DURING THE COURSE OF HER ENTIRE
CAREER THE STRONG ADVOCATE FOR
THE SUCCESS OF ALL STUDENTS.
ALL TOO OFTEN DISCUSSIONS
AROUND EDUCATION POLICY ARE
CAUGHT UP IN ADULT ISSUES. THAT
HAVE NEVER BEEN THE CASE WITH
INDIA SHE'S BEEN A FIERCE
EQUITY WARRIOR AND A LEADING
LIGHT OF OUR EFFORTS IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY TO ENSURE THAT
ALL STUDENTS LEAD THE K. TWELVE
SYSTEM. WELL PREPARED FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION AND THE
WORKFORCE FOR CONTRIBUTIONS TO
THE STATE BOARD HAVE ALREADY
BEEN SIGNIFICANT DURING THE
PAST YEAR. AND SHE WILL
CONTINUE TO BE A VALUABLE
CONTRIBUTOR TO THE BOARD'S
DELIBERATIONS MOVING FORWARD.
ON BEHALF OF THE ENTIRE RCOG
FAMILY WE URGE THE COMMITTEE
DEVELOP HI I'M DOCTOR GLOVER
WARDS CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS. A
LINE. SEVENTY SEVEN. I'M SURE
MEMBERS DOMINIC TOMARI ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION-
HERE IN SUPPORT OF DOCTORS
TECHNICAL APPROVAL MISTER JAMES
QUINLAN IMITATING RODRIGUEZ HAS
APPOINTMENTS TO STATE EDUCATION
BOARD THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON
AS- HI GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR
ATKINS AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE DINA BILL ON BEHALF
OF THE CAUSATION CATHOLIC
SCHOOL IN SHAPE WHEN STRONG ARM
FOR THE CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR
COMPUTER CLUB AND WHAT.
RODRIGUEZ AND JUDGING QUALITY
AS THEY HAVE ON OUR LIVES
ALREADY DEMONSTRATED THEIR
STRONG WORK ON THE WORK ORDER-
HE STRONGLY RIGHT THERE
COMPANIES AS WELL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. WINDS.
NINE GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CANDOR
BREAD AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES ASSOCIATION ALSO KNOWN
AS THE SETBACK I AM CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE APPOINTMENT OF
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION
MEMBERS RODRIGUEZ MCCLELLAN AND
DR GLOVER WHAT. ALL THREE
MEMBERS CURRENTLY SERVE ON THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION AND
EACH OF THEM BRING A UNIQUE AND
DIVERSE LINE TO THEIR DECISION
MAKING FOR THE COMPLICATED
ISSUES BROUGHT TO THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION IS AN
IMPORTANT POLICY MAKING BODY
AND THEIR DECISIONS DIRECTLY
AFFECT THE WORK OF COUNTY
OFFICES ESPECIALLY IN THE AREAS
OF ASSESSMENT CURRICULUM
INSTRUCTION AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS. ARE LETTERS OF SUPPORT
FOR EACH MEMBER FOR THEIR SHOW
HOW THE THREE CANDIDATES HAVE
DEMONSTRATED A WILLINGNESS TO
LISTEN LEARN AND THOUGHTFULLY
CONSIDER ALL THEIR DECISIONS
AND FOR THAT REASON WE ASK YOU
TO SUPPORT THEIR CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. WHY. SEVENTY
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
AFTER MCCARTY IN THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION I AM
CALLING TO EXPRESS STRONG
SUPPORT DR GLOBAL WOODS IN THE
CURRENT AND MAYES RODRIGUEZ
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. LINE SEVENTY ONE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MY NAME
IS BRANDON CHRISTIAN AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE VILLAGE
DEMAND STATEWIDE COALITION ON
BLACK AMERICAN AFFAIR. THE
ORGANIZATION OF LED BY FELLOW
DELTA SIGMA THETA GORE OF
DOCTORS TENDED WEBER WOOD DR
REGINA STANBACK STROUD. TODAY
WE ARE HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR
CYNTHIA GLOVER WOULD ACTUALLY
WILL HELP BRING IN THE DESIGN
PRINCIPLES AND LEADERSHIP
NECESSARY. TO FURTHER EDUCATE
THEIR MEDICATION OF ANTI
BLACKNESS IN EDUCATION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS. WHY.
EIGHTY GOOD AFTERNOON HI MADAM
CHAIR AND I COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS CARLOS MACHADO I AM
CALLING ON THE- CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS I'M SORRY CALIFORNIA-
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION- WE
ARE ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORTING
BE APPOINTMENTS TODAY AT SAN
DIEGO OVER WORDS AT RODRIGUEZ
AND GEMMA COLLINS WE APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THEIR
APPOINTMENTS AND URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE CONFIRMATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS.
MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTAT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'LL BE BACK WITH
YOU IN A MOMENT HAVING HEARD
FROM MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ARE
IN SUPPORT WE WILL BEGIN WITH
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE- FOR FOLKS WHO
MAY BE IN OPPOSITION- OKAY
SEEING. NO ONE APPROACH THE
PODIUM IN OPPOSITION ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE I NEED TO
GO LOOK AT ROOM ONE TWELVE. TO
MAKE SURE. THERE IS NO ONE
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE SO MISTER
MODERATOR WE ARE BACK WITH YOU
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
MAY WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
WE PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE THEN. ZERO MADAM CHAIR WE
AVE NO COMMENTS COMING THROUGH
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER MODERATOR- I WILL BRING
IT BACK TO MEMBERS OF MY
COLLEAGUE WE ARE OPERATING AS A
SUB COMMITTEE NOW WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM- I LET ME
JUST SAY WE HEARD FROM MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT. WHO
BROUGHT UP ISSUES OF RELEVANCE
THAT WERE OF A POLICY NATURE
THAT ARE REALLY NOT BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY THIS IS A
CONFIRMATION BUT I TRUST THAT
YOU WILL TAKE THE COMMENTS THAT
YOU HEARD FROM. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE WHO HAD THINGS TO
SAY AS WELL AS THOSE ON THE
PHONE THAT HIGHLIGHTED
ADDITIONAL ITEMS OF IMPORTANCE
TO THEM AND I WILL TRUST THAT
THAT HAS BEEN WELL RECEIVED AND
HEARD AND WITH THAT I WILL GO
TO SENATOR LAYER FOR A MOTION-
I THINK THEY- REALLY EXCELLED
INTO OF THE HEARING IN OUR
PRIVATE MEETINGS AND I'M
PLEASED TO MOVE ALL THREE. OF
CON FOR CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH US SENATOR LAYERED
MADAM SECRETARY. GROVE KAMLAGER
LAYERED HI LARRY I BATES ATKINS
AYE ATKINS AYE SO WE WILL WE
HAVE TO VOTES IN SUPPORT- AS I
SAID TO WE WILL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN- AS I SAID EARLIER WE HAVE
TO MEMBERS THAT ARE MULTI
TASKING BETWEEN COMMITTEES BUT
I THINK IF OUR- OTHER RECORDS
SERVERS ARE I ANTICIPATE A
POSITIVE REACTION- I THINK
MADAM VICE CHAIR WAS PRETTY
CLEAR IN HER SUPPORT OF YOU AS
WAS SENATOR CALM WATER BUT THAT
WILL BE CONFIRMED ONCE THEY
COME BACK AND ARE ABLE TO ADD
ON TO THE ROLE. WE WILL NOT
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN WITH MY
APPRECIATION AND THANKS AND- I
AM PRETTY SURE WE'RE GOING TO
SEE A POSITIVE OUTCOME HERE
GIVEN ALL OF THE CONVERSATION.
SO LET ME SAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND YOUR COMMENTS
TODAY AND THOUGH WE WILL
CONFIRM I MEAN WE WILL. ARE
WELL I GUESS WE'LL RECONFIRM
THE VOTE ONCE WE HAVE ALL OF
THE VOTES IN AND MAKE SURE THAT
YOU'RE AWARE- WITH THAT- AND
WITH MY GREAT THANKS TO THOSE
WHO ARE WAITING- AS PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
TRUSTEES WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
FIVE MINUTES- IN TERMS OF A
SHORT RECESS AND WE WILL BE
RIGHT BACK WITH YOU AND READY
TO GO. THANK YOU.
ORDER AND WE
WILL TURN OUR ITEMS ONE D.
THROUGH F. AND THAT ARE THE
APPOINTMENTS OF THREE MEMBERS
TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY BOARD OF TRUSTEES MR
DIEGO ARAMBULA WHO BY THE WAY I
LOVE THE PICTURE YOUR FAMILY WE
WERE WATCHING YOU IT IT BEFORE
THE MEETING CAME BACK TO ORDER-
SO WELCOME- OBVIOUSLY JACKBE
CLARK JUNIOR AND ANA ORTIZ MORE
FIT- I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND SITTING
THROUGH THAT CONVERSATION IT IS
A DAY OF EDUCATION SO MAYBE IT
WASN'T TOO PAINFUL. FOR YOU TO
HAVE TO SIT AND LISTEN TO YOUR
COUNTERPARTS ON THE STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION. BUT I WANT TO
WELCOME EACH OF YOU- WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP THE
INTRODUCTIONS IN THE ORDERS
THAT I JUST STATED- IN THE
ORDER OF THE AGENDA BEGIN AND
WITH MR DIEGO ARAMBULA AND I
AFTER. THAT YOU HAVE GIVEN YOUR
INTRODUCTION AND OPENING
COMMENTS I WILL. TURN IT OVER
TO- MISTER CLARK AND THEN MS
ORTIZ MARKET FOR EACH OF YOU TO
DO THAT FEEL FREE TO INTRODUCE
AND ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE YOU
WOULD LIKE IN YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS ONCE EACH OF YOU HAVE
INTRODUCED YOURSELF AND DONE
THAT I WILL GO TO MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS SO. I MR
ARAMBULA I WILL START WITH YOU.
WELCOME THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AN HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE- I'M SO
EXCITED TO BE HERE THE FORMER
EDUCATOR IN ME ALSO LOVED
HEARING. ABOUT ALL THE THINGS
ON THE STATE BOARD OF AND SO-
THAT WAS NOT PAINFUL AT ALL IS
REALLY EXCITING. I'M JOINED
HERE BY MY LOVELY AND WONDERFUL
WIFE CHANTELLE AM I CAN DO THIS
WITHOUT HER. AND MY DAUGHTERS
CAMILLA AND LOLA. WHO ARE THERE
AND THEIR- I'M JUST SO EXCITED
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY- I'VE
SPENT ALL OF MY PROFESSIONAL
LIFE IN PUBLIC EDUCATION.
BECAUSE I KNOW HOW
TRANSFORMATIONAL IT CAN BE MY
DAD WAS THE FIRST IN HIS FAMILY
BORN HERE IN THIS COUNTRY. THE
FIRST IN HIS FAMILY TO GO ON TO
COLLEGE- IN HIS PATH TO AND
THROUGH COLLEGE CHANGED HIS
LIFE. BY EXTENSION THEN CHANGED
MY LIFE THAT ARE MY SIBLINGS
AND HAS ALLOWED ME. TO CHANGE
THE LIVES OF MY OWN CHILDREN.
AND EVERY DAY I'M FIGHTING TO
TRY AND PROVIDE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MORE STUDENTS
TO SEE THAT TRANSFORMATION IN
THEIR OWN LIFE- I'VE DONE THIS
IS A CLASSROOM TEACHER AS A
HIGH SCHOOL PRINCIPAL AND NOW
SUPPORTING PRINCIPALS AND-
SUPERINTENDENTS ACROSS THE
STATE AND IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY. OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS HERE IN FRESNO I CONTINUE
TO GET MORE ENGAGED BOTH IN OUR
K. TWELVE SYSTEM AS WELL AS IN
OUR HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM-
ADVOCATING FOR A WHOLE HOST OF
SOLUTIONS THAT BETTER COMBINER
K. TWELVE SYSTEM INTO OUR
HIGHER ED SYSTEM- I HAVE SO
MUCH TO LEARN. IN IN CONTINUING
THIS JOURNEY TED TO FIND MORE
WAYS TO IMPACT PUBLIC EDUCATION
IS THE CSU TRUSTEE. I HAVE BEEN
WORKING DILIGENTLY I WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO. I'M SO
EXCITED TO PLAY. SOME ROLE AS A
BRIDGE BETWEEN K. TWELVE AND
HIGHER ED IN TO CONTINUE TO
ADVOCATE. FOR OUR PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM MORE BROADLY.
M. AS A CSU TRUSTEE. I'M I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU ARE MISTER CLARK
WELCOME. THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR
HONOR AND SENATORS- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY
WIFE WHO- TOOK OFF FROM WORK
RIVERSIDE MEDICAL CLINIC WHERE
SHE'S A REGISTERED DIETITIAN.
ON SHEILA WE'VE BEEN MARRIED
THIRTY YEARS- BYE BYE I KNOW
THAT MY DAUGHTER- THE RECENT
GRADUATE FROM UC RIVERSIDE. IS
LISTENING BY THE LIVE STREAM
I'M FORCING MY SON- OBJECT THE
THIRD- IT WAS NOT ABLE. TO
ATTEND THE IS ASSURED ME HE'S
GOING TO- LISTEN TO THE- TAPE
OF THIS BUT HE HAD TO WORK AT
THE- UC SANTA CRUZ BOOKSTORE
TODAY AND- WHERE HE'S A JUNIOR
SO HE WASN'T ABLE TO ATTEND-
JUST A LITTLE BIT ABOUT ME AND
I I'M I'M NOT TO TALK SO MUCH
ABOUT ME BUT IT IS MORE WHERE
I'M FROM- IN TERMS OF MY
UPBRINGING. MY MOTHER MY FATHER.
MY FATHER- JACKIE CLARK SENIOR-
WAS BORN IN SAN FRANCISCO- IN
THE FAMILY THAT DIDN'T HAVE A
LOT HE WAS ABLE TO GET AN
EDUCATION HE WAS A LOCAL TOWN
SOME CISCO STATE AND OTHER
UNITS AND OTHER UNIVERSITIES TO
ACHIEVE- UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE.
AND AS A RESULT HE WAS ABLE TO
COMPLETE A CAREER IN THE
CALIFORNIA'S AUTHORITY- UPON
HIS RETIREMENT. HE DECIDED HE'S
STILL ONE OF THE ABUSE AND-
BECAUSE OF THE OPPORTUNITIES OF
HIGHER EDUCATION. HE WAS ABLE
TO BECOME THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN TO SERVE ON THE STARK
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION. AND
THEM ALL SUBSEQUENT RUN IT
BECAME THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN TO REPRESENT MORE TO
ACTUALLY THE FIRST AFRICAN
HISTORY RIVERSIDE TO BE ON CITY
COUNCIL. MY MOTHER SORRY MOM.
MY MOTHER- FOR THOMAS MORRELL-
YOU CAME FROM VERY GOOD
BACKGROUNDS HIS HIS GRANDFATHER
WAS A SLAVE- BY RAPE TRIAL- HE
WAS ABLE TO GET TO SPEAK
UNIVERSITY AND- AS A RESULT OF
THAT EXPERIENCE HE WAS ABLE TO
COMPLETELY TRANSFORM TRAJECTORY
OF HIS LIFE- M. MY MOTHER'S
LIFE. THOSE VALUES OF
COMMITMENT TO HIGHER EDUCATION
WORKING FOR TOO MANY. AND AFTER
I WAS ABLE TO COMPLETE LAW
SCHOOL I WAS ABLE TO WORK FOR
VARIOUS PUBLIC AGENCIES BUT
MIKE PRACTICE FOR MOST OF MY
THIRTY PLUS YEARS OF INTERNET
HAS BEEN IN THE AREA OF
REPRESENTING OUR- PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM- AS A RESULT OF THAT-
AND IN CONJUNCTION WITH MY
EDUCATION. AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE OF SERVICE TO
MY COMPUTER AND VARIOUS
CAPACITIES WHETHER IT BE WORK
WITH THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
FOR SERVING AS A PRESENT HELLO
MY ASSOCIATION FOR OTHER
COMMUNITY ACTIVITIES- HELLO
SURE YOU ALL THAT I WILL BRING
ALL THAT EXPERIENCE TO THE BEST
OF MY ABILITY IF I'M CONFIRMED.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY I SURE YOU
WILL TAKE THIS EXTREMELY
SERIOUSLY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MS ORTIZ MORFORD WELCOME. YES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND-
STEAM SENATORS THIS IS SUCH A
GREAT HONOR- MY NAME IS ANA
ORTIZ MARKET AND I'M SO HONORED
TO BE HERE TODAY I'M SO EXCITED
ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE
AS A TRUSTEE FOR THE CSU
SYSTEM. I BELIEVE THAT ACCESS
TO HIGH QUALITY EDUCATION IS
THE GREATEST TOOL FOR SOCIAL
MOBILITY AND EDUCATION LET'S
NOT JUST STUDENTS BUT THE
ENTIRE FAMILY AND COMMUNITY. AS
A FIRST GENERATION STUDENT
MYSELF I'VE EXPERIENCED THIS
FIRST HAND. FOR THE PAST
FIFTEEN YEARS I'VE WORKED TO
SUPPORT UNDER REPRESENTED
GROUPS FIND A PATHWAY TO
COLLEGE. I FIND THIS WORK
INCREDIBLY MEANINGFUL AND
IMPORTANT AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THIS WORK AT THIS
YES YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR CONVERSATION
TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK EACH OF YOU- I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD AND TURN TO MY COLLEAGUES
AND I AM GOING TO AGAIN START
WITH YOU SENATOR LAYERED IF YOU
ARE. READY TO GO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IN OF. I ENJOYED MEETING
WITH ALL THREE OF YOU AND TO
MISTER CLARK IF THERE'S A
SECOND HEARING IN THEY DON'T
LAST YOUR SON OFF WORK AT THE
BOOKSHOP I WILL CALL THE
CHANCELLOR AND ASKED THAT HIS
SCHEDULE BE REARRANGED SO
PLEASE LET ME KNOW WHAT FOR. IF
THAT HAPPENS. HE YOU KNOW I
THINK THE INTERESTING THING IS
THAT EACH OF YOU. WHEN I TALK
TO YOU. I HAD A PERSONAL
MOTIVATION OUT OF PERSONAL
HISTORY AND- WHILE WE TALKED
ABOUT- OF PRACTICAL ISSUES LIKE
THE PROGRAM TO HAVE MORE PEOPLE%
COMPLETE CSU AND FOR YEARS
ABOUT ACCESS OF THE NUMBER OF
SPACES AND THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS. I THINK MAYBE I WOULD
JUST ASK EACH OF YOU. BECAUSE
OF MISS ORTIZ MORE FOR TALKED
ABOUT. A FIRST GENERATION
STUDENT OF MR ARAMBULA TALKED
ABOUT. HIS ENTIRE ADULT LIFE
AND EDUCATION DEDICATED AND
MISTER CLARK TALKED ABOUT. HIS
FAMILY BACKGROUND IN THE
COMMITMENT TO HIGHER EDUCATION
AND PUBLIC SERVICE. I THINK I'D
BE GOOD FOR EACH OF YOU TO TALK
ABOUT HOW YOU TAKE THAT
BACKGROUND THAT YOU ALL ENDED
UP LOSING TO IN YOUR OPENING
STATEMENT. AND HOW IT'S GOING
TO DRIVE YOU TOWARD WHAT GOALS
AS YOU SERVE OUR ON THE CSU
MAYBE WE'LL START WITH SOME.
DIDN'T IN OUR REVERSE GO- TO.
MR ARAMBULA THAN MISTER CLARK
AND MS ORTIZ MORE. THANK YOU MR
ARAMBULA GO RIGHT AHEAD. M.
APOLOGIES IN ADVANCE IF YOU
HEARD A FEW HERE VIRTUAL BANDS
IN THE BACKGROUND KAMALA IS NOW
BACK TO PLAYING THE TRUMPET-
BUT IN A DIFFERENT ROOM BUT
HOPEFULLY. DOESN'T MAKE ITS WAY
FOR ONE SENATOR COM ORDERS BACK
SHE WILL SERENADE WITH THEIR
SAXOPHONE AND THEY WERE
TOGETHER. I'M NOT SURE
COMMUNITIES THERE YET BUT WE'LL
TRY AND- SENATOR LAYERED THANKS
FOR THE TIME THE OTHER DAY AND
FOR THIS CHANCE TO JUST EXPAND
A LITTLE BIT MORE ON ON WHAT
THIS MOTIVATION MEANS AND HELP
WILL DRIVE TO WORK AND- I
THINK. THE WAY I GUESS I WOULD
THINK ABOUT THIS IS TWO FOLD.
M. ONE ON A VERY PERSONAL LEVEL.
I WILL JUST SAY I HAVE A DEEP
SENSE WHAT MY FRESHMAN YEAR OF
COLLEGE WAS INCREDIBLY HARD IT
IS IT IS FOR MOST KIDS- AND YET
I COULD CALL HOME TO TWO
PARENTS WHO WENT TO COLLEGE.
AND THEY COULD SAY YEP COLLEGE
IS HARD. HERE'S WHAT YOU NEED
TO DO AND COULD SORT OF TALK ME
THROUGH IT- IT WASN'T UNTIL
LATER THAT MY DAD SHARE THE
STORY OF CALLING HOME. AND HIS
MOM SAID WELL THEN COME HOME.
M. AND FOR SO MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS M. AN INMATE MAY I
BELIEVE THAT MY GRANDMA DID
THAT OUT OF PURE LOVE. I'M FOR
SO MANY OF OUR FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS THEY NEED A DEEP SENSE
THERE ARE SCHOOLS THAT ARE
UNIVERSITIES THAT ARE FACULTY
MEMBERS THAT OUR SYSTEMS ARE
GONNA THEM WHEN IT GETS HARD
BECAUSE IT WILL INEVITABLY GET
HARD AND SO MY DEEP BELIEF THAT
WE NEED TO DO THIS FOR ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS BUT ESPECIALLY FOR
FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS. IS
PROFOUND AND WILL HOPEFULLY
IMPACT ME TO CHECK TRYING TO
THINK ABOUT WAYS THAT AS A
SYSTEM WE CAN BEST MEET THE
NEEDS OF ALL OF OUR STUDENTS
AND ESPECIALLY. OUR OUR
STUDENTS WHO. HAVE BEEN
TRADITIONALLY THE MOST
MARGINALIZED. AND THE SECOND
WAY I THINK THIS IS IMPACTED ME
AS I'VE SEEN MORE AND MORE. THE
HUGE GAP WE HAVE TO FILL IT THE
STATE ESPECIALLY HERE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. HOW MANY MORE
COLLEGE GRADUATES WE NEED TO
TRULY. MEET THE DEMAND OF WHAT
THE WORKFORCE OF TOMORROW IS.
GOING TO REQUIRE. AND SO I JUST
HAVE THIS. DON'T KNOW HOW ELSE
TO DESCRIBE BESIDES A FIRE IN
MY BELLY SAID JUST MAKE SURE.
THAT OUR SYSTEMS AND FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS NOW I'VE BEEN
TRYING TO DO THIS AND IN HIGH
SCHOOLS- STROLL. FIRED UP ABOUT
THIS CHANCE TED TO CONTINUE
THIS WORK IN THE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM AND SO I THINK THAT
PERSONAL MOTIVATION I HAVE FROM
MY WHOLE LIFE STORY- ENCOURAGES
ME TO JUST KEEP THINKING ABOUT
HOW WE CAN DO BETTER FOR REAL
KIDS. AND HOW WE CAN DO BETTER-
FOR HER FOR HER COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF MISTER
CLARK. HELLO WE APPRECIATE AND
RECOGNIZE THAT. I COME FROM A
FAMILY IN WHICH I AM THIRD
GENERATION WHO WAS LUCKY ENOUGH
TO BE ABLE GO TO COLLEGE. BUT
BECAUSE OF MY MOTHER'S-
CONNECTION WITH THE SOLVE MY
FATHER'S. PERRANCE I PHAM
HEALTH. DEEP DEEP SENSE BUT WE
MUST PROVIDE. CAMPUS
COMMUNITIES. BETTER CONNECT
COMMITTED TO REFLECTING BY THE
STUDENTS THAT THEY SERVE.
PROVIDING THEM WITH THE ENTIRE
BILL STALLS OF SERVICES IN
ORDER TO MAXIMIZE THEIR
POTENTIAL FOR SUCCESS IN THE
COLLEGE ENVIRONMENT. ACHIEVING
AN UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE AS MY
COLLEAGUE JUST SAID IT'S HARD.
IT'S HARD FOR ANYBODY. BUT IF
YOU ARE STRUGGLING WITH BASIC
NEEDS. IF YOU CAN CONCORD
TRAUMA. IF YOU THEM ALL.
DISADVANTAGED OR- IF YOUR
BACKGROUND DOESN'T ARM. CONTAIN
THOSE ELEMENTS. YOU CAN STILL
BE STRUGGLING WILLIS THE
FEELING THAT YOU DON'T BELONG
THE FEELING THAT MAYBE YOU'RE
NOT SMART ENOUGH. AND SO. IN MY
CAPACITY AS THE TRUSTEE I WILL
DO EVERYTHING I CAN. TO SUPPORT
THE CHANCELLOR AND THE PRESENCE
OF THE TWENTY THREE
UNIVERSITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. TO HELP PREVENT VIOLENCE
WE'RE ALL YOUNG PEOPLE. WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY THE MAXIMUM
OPPORTUNITY AVAILABLE COULD BE
SUCCESSFUL. I WILL NEVER FORGET
THAT. THANK YOU Q. MISS ARE TOO
SMALL FOR. OF. IS IT REALLY
HELPED ME- COME TO THIS A
POSITION WITH A LOT OF EMPATHY
AND THE ISSUES THAT YOU KNOW I
EXPERIENCE AS A FIRST GEN
STUDENT AND THE ISSUES THAT
STUDENTS FACE STARED STILL
SIMILAR- AND YOU KNOW IN SOME
WAYS SOME THINGS ARE WORSE LIKE
THE COSTA LEVINE AND HOUSING-
YOU KNOW. THOSE THINGS IN
CALIFORNIA GOTTEN WORSE- SO I
HOPE TO HELP BRING FINANCIAL
SUPPORT TO STUDENTS A MOTIONAL
SUPPORT. AND ESPECIALLY I THINK
CRITICAL THE FIRST GEN STUDENTS
IS ADVISING SUPPORT- AND I AM
INCREDIBLY EXCITED ABOUT THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE BOTH MY
PARENTS ATTENDED CAL STATE LA
BUT THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO
FINISH AND- THEY HAD OTHER
CHALLENGES WITH STARTING A
FAMILY AND WORK. AND I THINK
ABOUT A PROGRAM LIKE THIS AND
THE TRANSFORMATIONAL EFFECT
IT'S GOING TO HAVE ON SO MANY
FAMILIES- WHO WILL BE ABLE TO
YOU KNOW BE SUPPORTED AND HAVE
THEIR CHILDREN AND BE ABLE TO
GRADUATE SO I THINK THAT'S
SUPER EXCITING TO ME- AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING THAT
INITIATIVE. AS A TRUSTEE. I'M
MADAM CHAIR LET ME JUST SAY
THANK YOU TO ALL THREE UNITS.
IT'S ACTUALLY FASCINATING
PUTTING THESE THREE WITH A
THREE WE JUST HEARD BECAUSE
THERE'S AN INCREDIBLE DIFFERENT
BACKGROUND FOR ALL SIX. AND
THEY ALL SEEM TO BE BRINGING
BACK WITH A PASSION. ARE IN THE
RIGHT WAY TO THIS SO MY LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING THEM I
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
ASK THEM QUESTIONS. CENTER
LAYERED THANK YOU MADAM VICE
CHAIR. WELL THANK YOU ALL- FOR
STEPPING FORWARD AND I AM I
THINK YOU MIGHT HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO PUSH YOURSELF TO THE
FRONT OF THE LINE BECAUSE YOU
ALL HAVE SUCH PASSION. TO DO
THIS JOB. CANDIDATES ARE
UNBELIEVABLE OF QUALIFIED- TO
WORK IN THIS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT NOT. ARENA WITH R.
OUR STATE UNIVERSITIES-
COMMENTED HAVE BEEN MADE TODAY
REALLY HIT HOME MOTHER HI I HAD
TO QUIT SCHOOL WHEN SHE WAS IN
THE NINTH GRADE. AND GO TO WORK
AND HELP OF SUPPORT HER FAMILY
SO HER PASSION ARE NOW SHE
ACTUALLY WAS ABLE TO OVERCOME
THAT- LACK OF FORMAL EDUCATION
IN KIND OF MOVE HERSELF UP INTO
SOME PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
POSITIONS THAT HE WAS.
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED THAT WE
WOULD FINISH HIGH SCHOOL ANDIT
MOST IMPORTANTLY WE WOULD ALL
GO TO COLLEGE SO- AT THE OLD
AGE OF FORTY TWO I CHOOSE FORTY
FOUR EXCUSE ME SHE LIED ABOUT
HER AGE. SO SHE COULD A JOB TO
MAKE A EXTRA MEN ON- AND
STARTED IN A- AND WORKED HER
WAY UP TO ON. PURCHASING AGENT
FOR A BIG- IF. NOW GAS COMPANY
OF MATTER OF FACT TO SO. WHAT
DRIVES PEOPLE IN TURN OF WHAT
AT. HAVING AN EDGE. I WOULDN'T
TO THEM. CERTAINLY THINK OUR-
TO YOUR BEING IF. THAT YOU ALL
OF THE X. AND HEARD FROM BOTH.
THE ALL OF THE ALL OF THE NEW
TODAY AND I THINK WE REAL
EMBRACE THAT WE IT YOU. ON YOU
ARE KIND TO POVERTY IN MANY I
WAS A SOCIAL WORK AND NOT A BIG.
IN MIKE THAT WE HAVE SO MANY.
WHO IN THE PROJECTS WERE MY
FIND THAT MY CASE. THAT REALLY
TRAPPED THERE AND SOME OF THE
YOUNG WE- ARE OUT WE LIKE MY
MOM ON WERE. TO FINISH HIGH
SCHOOL. I AM JUST THRILLED- YOU
ALL HAVE THAT PASSION IN THIS
AT THE LEVEL BECAUSE OUR STATE.
OF SO VERY IMPORTANT AS A
PATHWAY TO. THE CAREER PATHS
THAT OUR SON FOR THE PRESIDENT
FUTURE. SO THANK YOU FOR THAT
DEVICE. I BEEN OF FOLK IN MY ON
THE AND OF COAL BED. SO I'D
LIKE TO JUST START YOU. HE ONE
OF YOU GIVE ME A THOUGHTS. CHAU
THE FACT. IS THAT AND- OF GOING
BACK TO IN PER FOR. LIVE
ACTUALLY IT ALL LEVELS OF IT.
THAT IN. CSU AND UC A- THAT
THEY WERE STE. AND TO RECEIVE.
THE VACCINE ARE FOR THIS FALL.
IF THEY RECEIVE FULL- FDA
APPROVAL RIGHT NOW I GUESS IT'S
AN EMERGENCY. AND FOR WHAT IS
THE PLAN OR HAVE YOU EVEN
THOUGHT ABOUT. WHERE YOU GO YOU
HAVE FUN THE FDA DOESN'T ISSUE
A FULL APPROVAL. AND YOU DO
HAVE TO CONTINUE WITH SOME OF
THE HYBRID TEACHING MODELS THAT
HAVE BEEN OUT THERE BECAUSE WE
ALSO. ARE SEEING WITH OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE OUT OF CERTAINLY. THE
HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL AND ON. UP
THROUGH. COLLEGE REALLY BEING A-
BY ON. OUR THE ONLINE. LEARNING
IMPACT. PERHAPS THE MOTIVE THAT
YOU OF ALL HAVE THE YOU TO SUCH
YOU KNOW HIGHER. SAID I THINK
IT'S TROUBLE TO ALL OF US. SO
YOU'RE FOR ON HOW YOU MIGHT BE
ABLE TO. YOU KNOW DO YOU DO THE
JOB THAT YOU ALL WANT TO DO AND
MAKE SURE THAT OUR KIDS ARE. OF
BEING PROVIDED THE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE IN THE REAL
WORLD I'M NOT THE VIRTUAL WORLD
OF EDUCATION AND ALL SOCIAL
INTERACTION THOSE THINGS ARE SO
IMPORTANT TO MATURATION. LET
ME- GO AHEAD AND START IN
REVERSE ORDER AND MISS ORTIZ
MARKET YOU WANT TO TAKE THIS
FIRST AND MISTER CLARK YOU'LL
STAY IN THE MIDDLE OF THE PACK
AND THEN WE'LL FINISH UP WITH
MR ARAMBULA. GO AHEAD. YES YOU
HAS ANNOUNCED THAT THEY WILL
REQUIRE ALL STUDENTS FACULTY
AND ADMINISTRATION TO BE
VACCINATED- I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THIS- THEY WILL ALLOW
EXCLUSIONS FOR MEDICAL OR
RELIGIOUS REASONS WHICH I THINK
IS ALSO QUITE IMPORTANT- THERE.
OTHER SAFETY MEASURES FOR
VISITORS AND THOSE WHO ARE
UNABLE TO BE VACCINATED- THAT
THEY WILL ANNOUNCE AND THAT'S
KIND OF WHERE THAT THE SYSTEM
IS RIGHT NOW- THEY'RE WORKING
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. SO
THAT MOST CAMPUSES WILL SERVICE
VACCINES SITES WHICH IS BEEN A
GREAT OFFERING TO THAT LOCAL
COMMUNITIES- I THINK. YOU KNOW
ROLLING OUT THE VACCINE TO THE
CAMPUSES- IF IT CAN BE DONE IN
A TIMELY FASHION. WOULD IT
SUPPORT EVERYONE REPOPULATING
THE CAMPUSES WHICH I'M IN
SUPPORT OF I THINK THAT IS
GREAT TO HAVE STUDENTS BACK ON
CAMPUS AND LEARNING THEIR I
THINK. WE'VE LEARNED THAT
ONLINE LEARNING CAN BE
EFFECTIVE BUT I THINK THAT-
IT'S MOST EFFECTIVE WITH
STUDENTS IN THE CLASSROOM SO
I'M HOPING THAT THAT CAN BE
ROLLED OUT AFFECTED LEE AND- I
THINK ANNOUNCING THAT VACCINES
ARE REQUIRED IS. A GOOD FIRST
STEP. IN THAT DIRECTION. THANK
YOU MR CLARK. THANK YOU I WOULD
GENERALLY AGREE WITH EVERYTHING
THAT WAS SAID I THINK- THAT
THE- SYSTEM- THAT AT AN
OUTSTANDING JOB ON IN THE FACE
OF A GLOBAL PANDEMIC
ESTABLISHED- THROUGH- FACULTY
TRAINING AND EIGHTY EXTREMELY.
AGILE AND NIMBLE AS WELL AS
BODY GROUP AND STAFF- THAT THEY
ARE ABLE TO- MEET THE ETCETERA.
AND SO IN THAT REGARD- I'VE
REALLY WATCHES CAMPUS IS AS
MUCH AS- I DO KNOW THAT-
THERE'S NEXT THAT THERE WILL
HAVE TO BE MORE IN TERMS OF ALL
PRESENTS. SOME INCREASE IN THE
BOB NUMBER OF CLASS THAT MY CAN
TAKE ONLINE BECAUSE BE SOME OF
THE ON THAT- BUT THE- THE
REQUIREMENT OF BACKS. AS A
GENERAL SEEMS TO BE A LOT OF
ONE LOGICAL THE SPACE ON
DOESN'T- THIS YEAR'S USES TO
IMMENSE FACULTY STAFF- HAVE A
STEP WAS A TRACTOR OF BEING
ABLE TO RISE THE MOMENT FROM
CONFIRMS ALL DO EVERYTHING IN
MY POWER TO SO THEM. BUT I AM
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE DRIVE TO
ENSURE- FOLKS ARE VAST
VACCINATED PENDING THE FDA
APPROVAL- I BELIEVE THAT WHERE
WE ARE NOW UNLESS SAID.
PERFECTLY WE'VE NAME THAT WE'VE
GOT AN INITIAL POLICY. M. CSU
STAFF IS NOW IN CONVERSATIONS
WITH. LABOR UNIONS WITH FACULTY
GROUPS WITH STUDENT GROUPS AND
TO SEE HOW WE CAN ROLL THIS OUT
ON IN THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY
SO- I'M I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THAT AND WOULD CONTINUE TO BE
IF CONFIRMED. M. I ALSO JUST
WANTED TO NOTE SENATOR BATES
THANK YOU FOR SHARING YOUR
STORY ABOUT YOUR MOM. AND MY
MOM WENT BACK TO SCHOOL WHEN I
WENT OFF TO COLLEGE AND SO AM I
HAVE FOND MEMORIES OF CALLING
HOME. AND AT BOTH OF US
LAMENTING ABOUT WRITING PAPERS.
NO I THINK WE INSPIRED MY MOM
AND WE WERE GOING TO COLLEGE
BECAUSE SHE DID GET A REAL
ESTATE LICENSE BY PUTTING A
BOOK I REMEMBER THEY ALSO
PUTTING A BOOK ON ON THE
KITCHEN SINK IN WHAT SHE'S
DOING THE- COOKING AND ALL OF
THAT AFTER WORK OF COURSE SHE
WAS READING ON. READING THE
REAL ESTATE LICENSE BOOKS SO
SHE COULD PASS THE LOCATE. THE
LICENSURE AND UP SO I WAS SHE
HAD- CERTAINLY ON THAT
EXPERIENCE THAT REALLY WAS
SEEING HER PARENTS LOSE. THEIR
JOBS AND- THEIR WEALTH WHICH
THEY DIDN'T HAVE MUCH OF ANYWAY
THEY HAD CHILDREN. DIED DURING
THE DEPRESSION IT WAS A REAL
MOTIVATING FACTOR FOR THAT
GENERATION AND I THINK WE CALL
IT THE GREATEST GENERATION.
THEY WERE CERTAINLY ARE GIVEN
BY MANY OF THE EXPERIENCES THEY
HAD AND THAT'S WHAT'S GREAT
ABOUT WHAT ALL OF YOU HAVE SAID
ABOUT YOUR EXPERIENCES. AND HOW
THAT IS MOTIVATED YOU TO REACH
OUT ARE SHARING THOSE. THROUGH
A VERY IMPACTFUL WAY- INSURING
THAT EVERYONE EVERYONE HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY IN THIS STATE AND
IN THE NATION. TO RISE ABOVE.
THEIR BEGINNING FAN ACHIEVE
FONG THEY MERICAN DREAM SO WE
THANK YOU FOR THAT. I THINK I'M
I DON'T I HAVE ONE OTHER
QUESTION BUT I'M GOING TO. MOVE
ON TO MY COLLEAGUE SO THAT THEY
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY. BETTER
AGAIN ON I CHEER YOU AND WISH
YOU THE VERY. BEST THING YOU
CERTAINLY WILL HAVE MY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SENATOR. AND IF WE
NEED TO COME BACK WE CANNOT
LEAVE THAT UP TO YOU- SENATOR
COME LONGER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRO TEM UM AND I TOO WILL BE A
SUPPORTING AT THESE
APPOINTMENTS- THIS AFTERNOON I
HAVE JUST A FEW QUESTIONS AND I
DON'T NECESSARILY KNOW WHO TO
DIRECT THEM TO AND I DON'T WANT
TO BE RANDOM SO MAYBE MADAM FOR
TIME YOU CAN- TAKE THE- PERSON-
YOU KNOW I ACTUALLY. CAME FROM.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE WORLD AND
I SAT ON A- A DISTRICT A BOARD-
WITH NINE CAMPUSES IT WAS THAT
LARGE. AND SO EVEN THOUGH I
LIVED IN A PARTICULAR PART OF
THE CITY- AND HAD A SPECIFIC
SCHOOL IN MY BACKYARD IT WAS MY
RESPONSIBILITY AS A BOARD
MEMBER- TO REALLY. SORT OF
PROVIDE. OVERSIGHT TO THE
ENTIRE DISTRICT. TO ALL NINE OF
THE COLLEGE CAMPUSES YOU ALL
HAVE TWENTY THREE- AND IN
READING YOUR- A BIOS AND
RESPONSES YOU ALL ALL COME FROM
VERY DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
STATE. AND PROBABLY HAVE SOME-
PREFERENCES IN TERMS OF EITHER
THE SCHOOLS OR THE PARTS OF THE
STATE- THAT YOU. ALIGN YOURSELF
MOST CLIENTS MOST CLOSELY WITH
AND YET- WILL HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT TO TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES. SO JUST WOULD LOVE
YOUR THOUGHTS ON. YOU KNOW
MAYBE HOW YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
PICK FAVORITES OR MAYBE HOW YOU
ARE GOING TO- PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
AND SUPPORT AND GOVERNANCE TO
THE ENTIRE- SYSTEM- MAYBE
PICKING ISSUES OR REGION'S. NOT
A FAMILIAR TO YOU OR- IF THERE
ARE ISSUES THAT MAYBE RESONATE
WITH YOU PERSONALLY- THAT
REVEAL THEMSELVES IN- PARTS OF
THE STATE OR ON CAMPUS IS THAT
YOU'RE NOT MOST FAMILIAR WITH.
IT'S SOMEWHAT OF A CONVOLUTED
QUESTION BUT I HOPE YOU GET THE
GIST OF IT- WHICH IS. HOW TO
KIND OF PROVIDE THAT KIND OF
MACRO OVERSIGHT- TO A SYSTEM
WITH TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES OUT
WHILE RECOGNIZING YOU ALL MIGHT
HAVE AFFINITIES TWO ONE OR A
COUPLE BASED ON- YOUR OWN
PERSONAL LIFE EXPERIENCES AND
WHERE YOU RESIDE. THANK YOU MR
CLARK LET ME START WITH YOU
THIS TIME IN FAIRNESS AND
EQUITY FOR ALL THREE. GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU ALL TRY THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION- WILL AGAIN BUT
LET ME LET ME GO BACK TO A
LITTLE BIT OF MY BACKGROUND- I
HAVE BEEN BORN IN SACRAMENTO MY
DAD WORKED FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO WHEN I WAS AN
INFANT OR ITS GONNA TALLER WE
MOVED RIVERSIDE AND THEN WE
WILL NORWALK. I BET SOME
FRANCISCO- I AM I WENT TO LAW
SCHOOL IN SACRAMENTO. ALL I
HAVE TO GO TO- UC RIVERSIDE BUT
I DISCLOSED THIS ON AS A
FRESHMAN IN UNDERGRADUATE
SCHOOL I STARTED AT CAL POLY
SAN LUIS OBISPO- I HAVE BEEN IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE- I
HAVE WORKED WITH PROFESSIONAL
EDUCATORS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND WHILE BECAUSE I'VE BEEN A
RESIDENT RIVERSIDE CHORE- MOST
OF MY LIFE- I DO HAVE A
UNDERSTANDING OF THIS REGION.
BUT ON THE WILL NOT BE
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO- BE ABLE
TO. BOB GET TO LEARN I WOULD
PUT HIM ON ONE OF THE RESPONSES
I SEE EACH ON CAMPUS AS KIND OF
ITS OWN ECOSYSTEM IT'S ALL
CONNECTIONS WITH ITS OWN
COMMUNITIES. WHERE IT GETS ITS
STUDENTS FROM AM I LOOK FORWARD
TO- ONE VISITING ALL OF THOSE
CAMPUSES I'M GETTING TO KNOW
THE STAFF FACULTY AND
ADMINISTRATION ALL THOSE
CAMPUSES AND SO- WHY I'M ABOUT
RIVERSIDE RESIDENT- I DON'T
THINK I'M GONNA HAVE A
DIFFICULT TIME. MAINTAINING MY
OLD OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITY IN
TERMS OF VOTING AS A MEMBER OF
THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES I'M
TRYING TO SUPPORT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE MUCH OF
WHAT WE CAN I'M TRYING TO BE OF
A RESOURCE ON THROUGH MY BOOKS
ON BOARD. TO ALL TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES. I YOU- MISS ORTIZ YOU
WANNA. TACK THAT ONE. YES SURE
WELL I FORGET WHICH SENIOR
ADMINISTRATOR SAID THIS COMMENT
BUT IT WAS SOMETHING TO THE
EFFECT THAT- EACH OF THE TWENTY
THREE CAMPUSES ARE CHILDREN.
AND YOU KNOW YOU LOVE THEM ALL
BUT IT'S JUST YOU LOVE THEM
DIFFERENTLY AND AS A MOTHER OF
FOUR I CAN RELATE TO THAT SO I
THINK THAT'S THE WAY THAT I
WOULD LOOK AT BEST BET. NO
THEY'RE THEY'RE ALL IMPORTANT
AND HAVE DIFFERENT STRENGTHS
AND WEAKNESSES AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO EDUCATE MYSELF AS
A TRUSTEE- LIKE JACK MENTIONED
I'D LOOK FORWARD TO VISITING
AND GOING TO DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE STATE THAT I'M NOT AS
FAMILIAR WITH- AND I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO.
REALIZE THAT EACH CAMPUS HAS
DIFFERENT NEEDS AND YOU KNOW
THERE'S NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
BUT ALSO TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE MAY BE BEST PRACTICES
ACROSS THE SYSTEM THAT WE CAN
IMPLEMENT SO. I THINK YOU KNOW
HAVING THE BIG PICTURE VIEW BUT
THEN ALSO UNDERSTANDING THE
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS OF EACH CAMPUS
ARE IMPORTANT AND- EVEN THOUGH
I DO HAVE YOU KNOW. MANY CSU'S
IN MY BACKYARD IN THE BAY AREA
I DO THINK THAT- YOU KNOW I'M
JUST AS CURIOUS AND INTERESTED
TO LEARN ABOUT THE ONES I DON'T
KNOW ABOUT AND YOU KNOW SEE
WHAT SORT OF PROGRAMS AND
THINGS THAT ARE INTERESTING ARE
GOING ON THERE. SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT. MISTER ROMULUS.
I'LL SAY GO BULLDOGS- LIKE I
GREW UP TWO AND A HALF MILES
FROM FRESNO STATE- WE WENT
THERE ALL THE TIME IS AS KIDS I
WENT TO SUMMER CAMPS THERE- WE
DO HAVE TWENTY THREE KIDS AND I
CERTAINLY HAVE AN AFFINITY FOR
ONE- BUT TO WHAT I NAMED JACK
SHARED. I AM SO PART OF THE
REASON THAT I HAVE THIS
AFFINITY AS IT'S BEEN IN MY
BACKYARD AND IT'S THE SCHOOL A
NOTE MOST CLOSELY. I ALSO
OPENED HIGH SCHOOL TWO AND A
HALF MILES FROM SAN JOSE STATE.
SO I CAN SAY GO SPARTANS. MY
SISTER GRADUATED FROM SAN
FRANCISCO STATE- SO I AM I HAVE
CONNECTIONS TO A NUMBER- AND
I'M- REALLY REALLY EXCITED. AS
WE START TRAVELING AGAIN TO
START VISITING MORE SCHOOLS AND
TO START DEVELOPING WORK HAVE
ANY AFFINITY AND JUST MORE AND
UNDERSTANDING OF THE NEEDS OF
VARIOUS PARTS OF THE STATE AND-
I CERTAINLY. HOPE TO BRING SOME
AWARENESS OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AS YOU KNOW US FRESNO FOLKS
SOMETIMES THINK THE MIDDLE AND
THE STATUS IS A LITTLE
FORGOTTEN. BUT CERTAINLY YOU
SEE ANY ROLE I PLAY ON- IF I'M
APPOINTED. TO M. B. ONE OF THE
MANY VOICES THINKING ABOUT ALL
TWENTY THREE OF OUR SCHOOLS AND
ALL OF OUR AUXILIARY CAMPUS IS
JUST ONE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THAT- AND YOU KNOW- MISTER
CLARK. YOU MENTIONED WANTING TO
BE SUPPORTIVE OF- THE
CHANCELLOR AND HIS EFFORTS AND
SO JUST WHAT I WANTED TO ASK
THIS QUESTION OF YOU IT WAS ONE
THAT- I HAD ATTACKED. ONE
ENGINE OF YOU COULD JUST SORT
OF SHARE WITH US WHAT THE
RELATIONSHIP IS LIKE BETWEEN
THE TRUSTEES- AND THE
CHANCELLOR- THAT'S THE FIRST
QUESTION BECAUSE I THINK THAT
RELATIONSHIP IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT IN WAYS IN WHICH IT
IS BUILT. ON AND SUPPORTED IT
IS IMPORTANT TO THE SYSTEM. AND
THEN THE SECOND QUESTION IS
THAT TRUSTEES ALSO. ELECT
CAMPUS- PRESIDENTS AND SO
WANTED TO KNOW IF- YOU. KNOW
ACTUALLY HOW THE PRESIDENT'S
COMPENSATION- IS DETERMINED AND
THEN WHAT FACTORS ARE KIND OF
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION WHEN
MAKING THAT DETERMINATION. THE
REASON WHY I ASK IS BECAUSE I
HAVE A- A SCHOOL IN MY
DISTRICT- WELL NOT IN MY
DISTRICT BUT A DECENT. AND
THESE ARE QUESTIONS THAT HAVE
COME UP SO I'M I GUESS YOU
COULD SAY I'M ASKING FOR A
FRIEND. MISTER CLARK YEAH
CERTAINLY- WELL THE CHANCELLOR-
HAS ONLY BEEN THE CHANCELLOR
SENSE LONG LAST FALL NOVEMBER
AFFECTED- CHANCELLOR EMERITUS
JIM WHITE WAS LEAVING- WHEN I
ATTENDED MY FIRST MEDIA
NOVEMBER- I WOULD SAY- SO FAR
THE CHAT THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN- THE BOARD. OF TRUSTEES
AND THE CHANCELLOR HAS BEEN
POSITIVE- HE DOES M. PROCESS-
FILLING SOME SLOTSHOME WHERE
PEOPLE HAVE LEFT FOR OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES- BUT- I WAS
FAMILIAR WITH THOSE- THE
CHANCELLOR EMERITUS- I SAW HIM
CHAIR ONE MEETING- AND THE
CHANCELLOR. AND THE AND THE
WITH THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES
THOUSAND GROUP SEEMS TO BE
RESPECTFUL- AND- I THINK AT
THIS POINT HELP- IN TERMS OF
HOW- ABOUT RESIDENTS
COMPENSATION IS- IS ADDRESS
WILL WE JUST COME UP WE JUST
HAD AN EXPERIENCE WHERE A BRAND
NEW CHANCELLOR HAPPENS TO BE AT
FRESNO STATE- I CALLED MY
COLLEAGUE TRUMP WROTE. THIS IS
HAPPY ABOUT THAT. AND WE
ANNOUNCED IS- ON EXECUTIVE
COMPENSATION AT THE MEETING
TODAY- AND HE IS GETTING PAID
THE SAME AMOUNT- HE WAS ON PAID
AS THE INTERIM CHANCELLOR. I DO
KNOW- IN FACT I'M I'M A MEMBER
OF THE SUBGROUP IS LOOKING AT
THE ISSUE OF ON EXECUTIVE
COMPENSATION- I EXPECT THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE TAKING UP THAT
ISSUE. THE CURRENT POLICY-
ENVISIONS- COMPENSATION ON TO
BE DECIDED- BASED UPON
PRINCIPLES OF RESOURCE FOR AND
THAT'S WHAT THE MARKET STATES
AND I DO KNOW THAT ON THE BOARD
OF TRUSTEES WILL BE TAKING THAT
OUT. AT SOME LENGTH- LATER THIS
YEAR. GREAT YOU FOR THAT- AS I
MENTIONED I'LL BE M. SUPPORTING
THE APPOINTMENTS TODAY I THINK
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT- JOB AND I THINK
THERE ARE GREAT OPPORTUNITIES
TO STRENGTHEN THE PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THE CSU'S AND THE UC'S. I WOULD
JUST ALSO LIKE TO REMIND YOU
ALL IN LIGHT OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH SURVEY THAT'S BEING
CONDUCTED- FOR THE CSU'S OF THE
STUDENTS THAT WE HAVE SO MANY
STUDENTS IN YOUR SYSTEM THAT.
OUR FOSTER YOUTH- THAT ARE
HOUSING AND FOOD AND SECURE-
AND THAT REALLY NEED A SYSTEM
THAT SUPPORTS- ALL OF THE-
ELEMENTS OF WHAT IT MEANS TO BE
A SUCCESSFUL STUDENT. IT IS
HARD TO LEARN WHEN YOU DON'T
KNOW WHERE YOU'RE GOING TO BE
SLEEPING AT NIGHT. IT IS HARD
TO LEARN WHEN YOUR BELLY IS
EMPTY. IT IS HARD TO LEARN WHEN
YOU ARE IN A SYSTEM OR A
SITUATION WHERE THERE IS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE- IT IS HARD
TO LEARN WHERE YOU ARE AFRAID
OF ICE IS GOING TO SHOW UP ON
YOUR CAMPUS. AND YANK YOU AWAY
FROM YOUR FAMILY AND THESE ARE
ISSUES THAT WE ARE ASKING OUR
STUDENTS TO DEAL WITH- EVERY
SINGLE DAY. AND I THINK AS
TRUSTEES YOU ALL HAVE AN
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY IN FRONT
OF YOU. TO HELP MITIGATE SOME
OF THOSE CHALLENGES SO THAT OUR
STUDENTS CAN GO TO OUR SCHOOLS.
AND FOCUS ON THEMSELVES- AND ON
THEIR ABILITY TO LEARN. AND IN-
JUST RESPONDING TO WHAT YOU
SAID EARLIER MISTER CLARK YOU
KNOW THERE'S A ARE A STATISTIC
OUT THERE THAT SAYS. YOU KNOW
THAT OF THE 50% 56% OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS HAVE. COLLEGE DEGREES
AND LESS THAN A THIRD OF THEM.
OUR HOMEOWNERS. AND SO THERE IS
A- DISCONNECT BETWEEN OUR
ACCESS TO EDUCATION. AND ACCESS
TO CAPITAL AND ECONOMIC SUCCESS
AND WHILE THE NUMBERS ARE NOT
EXACTLY THE SAME ACROSS ALL
ETHNICITIES ON THERE ARE
STRIKING SIMILARITIES WITH
OTHER GROUPS AND SO I JUST
LEAVE THAT WITH EACH OF YOU ALL
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE I THINK A AN
OPPORTUNITY TO KIND OF HELP
FOLKS LEARNING GRADUATE BUT
GIVE THEM WITH THE TOOLS THAT
THEY NEED. TO BE ABLE TO OPEN
OTHER DOORS- OF ACCESS EQUITY
CAPITAL- IN GENERAL EQUITY SO
FIGHT ON. THANK YOU SENATOR COM
LAGER- I WOULD JUST SAY BETWEEN.
LISTENING TO THE APPOINTEES TO
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION
AND HERE IN EACH OF THE THREE
OF YOU TALK. IT YOU KNOW. I
STARTED OUT THIS MORNING
TALKING TO A GROUP OF YOUNG
WOMEN WHO ARE PART OF IT. AN
ORGANIZATION CALLED EMERGE A
CLASS ALL WOMEN. AND I GOT TO
HEAR A FEW STORIES- THIS
MORNING I GOT THE YOU KNOW TO
HEAR THE STORIES OF- THE
PREVIOUS- CONFEREES AND HEAR
YOUR STORIES AND YOUR
EXPERIENCE AS IT RELATES TO
BEING. A FIRST GENERATION I
KNOW YOU'RE NOT ALL FIRST
GENERATION BUT YOU KNOW. WE ALL
HAVE OUR STORIES AND THAT
INFORMS OUR PASSION FOR WHAT WE
DO AND WHY WE DO IT AND- YOU
KNOW TO- TO THE POINT OF MR
ARAMBULA THAT YOU HAVE THE
ABILITY TO CALL YOUR PARENTS
AND- STATE DAY MAJOR YOU WILL
STAY IN SCHOOL MY PARENTS WERE
NOT. COLLEGE GRAD I WAS THE
FIRST TO GO TO COLLEGE AND
GRADUATE AND- THANKFULLY I WAS
ONLY TWO HOURS FROM HOME BUT IT
MIGHT AS WELL HAVE BEEN THREE
THOUSAND MILES. FOR MY FAMILY
WHO DIDN'T HAVE TRANSPORTATION
AND I WENT TO A RURAL SCHOOL.
IN SOUTHWEST VIRGINIA IT'S HARD
AND I CAN ONLY IMAGINE IT'S
HARDER TODAY IT'SHARDER TODAY.
WITH THE DIVERSITY IN OUR STATE
AND THAT AND THE SOCIAL ISSUES
AND- THE LACK OF RESOURCES- IT
IS HARDER AND I THINK YOU SPOKE
TO THAT SENATOR COM LONGER. BUT
I JUST HAVE TO SAY TO MISTER
CLARK'S COMMENT EDUCATION IS
THE KEY I WOULD NOT BE HERE
TODAY WITHOUT HAVING HAD THAT
ABILITY. TO GET A COLLEGE
EDUCATION AND TO KNOW THAT I
COULD ASPIRE TO MORE. AND SO
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT ISSUES LIKE
THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE- THE
ISSUE SAID SENATOR COM LAGERS
SPOKE ABOUT THE ISSUES THAT WE
ARE DEALING WITH THAT THE
BUDGET OUT IT. CERTAINLY BUDGET
RESOURCES AND SENATOR LAYERED
AND- OBVIOUSLY APPROPRIATIONS
ALL OF THESE ISSUES THAT WE'RE
GRAPPLING WITH GET TO THE HEART
OF WHAT YOU ALL TALKED ABOUT
TODAY. IT IS HOW WE SUPPORT.
WITH RESOURCES. OUR STUDENTS.
ARE FOR THEIR OWN INDIVIDUAL
ABILITIES BUT ALSO FOR THE
ECONOMY OF OUR STATE. I AS WELL
AS ACCESS TO OPPORTUNITY SO
IT'S BEEN A IT'S BEEN A REAL
JOY TO LISTEN TO YOU TALK AND
TO TELL YOUR STORIES BECAUSE
YOUR STORIES INFORM. HOW WE
APPROACH THINGS AND SO- AGAIN I
READ I READ THE RESPONSES I
READ YOUR YOUR COMMENTS AND I
WILL SAY- ONE OF THE BEST
THINGS ABOUT BE IN THE FORMER
SPEAKER. AS I GOT TO SIT ON THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES AND SO I KNOW
THE ISSUES TO GRAPPLE WITH. I
WORK VERY WELL WITH THE FORMER
CHANCELLOR WHO I HAD A GREAT
DEAL OF RESPECT FOR AND- HAVE I
AM LOOKING FORWARD TO DEALING
WITH- OUR NEW CHANCELLOR. AND
TO SEE THAT YOU ARE ABLE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL WITH THESE
INITIATIVES THAT GET US FURTHER
AND FURTHER. TO FIND WAYS TO
SUPPORT OUR ON OUR STUDENTS AND
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE AN
ABUNDANCE OF RICHES- TWENTY
THREE CAMPUSES- YOU KNOW I
THINK OUR CHALLENGES HOW WE
PROVIDE THE SUPPORT AND
RESOURCES THAT YOU NEED TO DO
THIS JOB. AND TO OVERSEE WHAT
WE NEED TO DO AND CERTAINLY A
PANDEMIC DID NOT HELP. OUR
ABILITY AS WE WERE MAKING
STRIDES FORWARD ON. THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE ON
SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS. SO I'M
GLAD YOU EACH HAVE THE PASSION
THAT WE'VE ALL TALKED ABOUT
TODAY MULTIPLE TIMES- I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND- I WITH
THAT I WANT TO SEE WHAT MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC ARE HERE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT AND WE'RE GONNA
START WITH THAT. I'M GONNA LOOK
IN THE ROOM HERE IN THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE- TO SEE IF WE HAVE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
I DO NOT SEE ANYONE APPROACHING
THE PODIUM I'M GOING TO GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE AND TAKE A LOOK
AND SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE THERE.
AND I DO NOT SEE ANYONE SO
MISTER MODERATOR I KNOW YOU'RE
STILL WITH US I'M GOING TO
WELCOME YOU BACK TO OUR HEARING
AND SEE IF YOU WILL T. UP THE-
INDIVIDUALS THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
IN SUPPORT. PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO. NECROMANTIC ENDED
ONE THEN ZERO. AND WHILE WE'RE
WAITING FOR THEM TO TF I WANT
TO REMIND FOLKS THAT WHEN YOU
SPEAK I NEED YOU TO PROVIDE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION OF ANY
AND A VERY BRIEF- POSITION. ON
THE APPOINTMENT AND AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF OUR COURT REPORTER
SPEAK SLOWLY AND CLEARLY GO
AHEAD MR MODERATOR. IN A LINE
SEVENTY THREE OR MY COULD OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON KATRINA RENDON
ON BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY. PART OF
THE APPOINTMENT OF JACKIE CLARK
AND GET THE IRAQI LIKE TO SEE
IF YOU PUT A CHECK THE- BOX
CARE THE CAMPAIGN UPDATED OUR
GROUND BREAKING LESS BOND
COMPANY THREE. BUT SHALL NOT
ONLY DO DENTURE STILL
CRITICALLY UNDERREPRESENTED ON
A COLLEGE UNIVERSITY GOVERNING
BOARDS SHOULD BE QUITE WE HAVE
MISTER JACK CLARK AS A BLACK
MAN IN THE INLAND EMPIRE AND OF
MR DIEGO RANDY LAST NIGHT NOT.
VALLEY ARE VITAL STEPS
INCLUDING RACIAL AND REGIONAL
APPLICATION CAPS. ON OUR STATE
GOVERNMENT BOARD. WHAT HAPPENS.
THAT REFLECTS A DIVERSE OF
RUSHED. LEADERS SAID BUT I'M-
THE BALL AND IMPACTFUL FOR ME.
FURTHER MR ARAMBULA OF THE ON
THE AT THE CEILING. THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. SOMEONE WILL THREE ONE
THAT TWENTY SEVEN TO BY MYSELF
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND MY.
ADDITIONAL THERE ARE ONLY TWO
OTHER BLACK CAL. AND ONE MEMBER
THE INNER ON THE BOARD. THANK
YOU MISTER CAR COMPLETELY BY
DON'T ANYBODY AND SHE REGION
POPULAR BUT OUR STATE GREAT-
THEIR VOICES AND ENJOY OUR CREW
TOWARD BETTER MEET THE NEEDS
YES HE'S THAT ALL THE
GOVERNMENT DEPARTMENTS TO BOARD
ENCOURAGE BIBLE TO CONFIRM HIM.
AROUND THE LINE O'CLOCK TODAY
THE YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WITNESS.
WHY. EIGHTY TWO. IT MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS DOMINIC TOMORROW ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
APPOINTMENT OF ALL THREE
CANDIDATES. MISTER CLARK. AND
MR BUSH'S MARKET THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. AND MADAM CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY I'M GONNA COME BACK INTO
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM OF MEMBERS
IN SUPPORT TO SEE IF THERE IS
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION. I
STILL SEE NO MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE. I SEE NO ONE
APPROACHING THE PODIUM IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE SO MISTER MODERATOR
WE ARE BACK WITH YOU. THANK YOU
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. NET COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE ZERO. N. MADAM CHAIR THERE
ARE NO COMMENTS COMING THROUGH
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER MODERATOR FOR YOUR HELP
AND SUPPORT TODAY WE APPRECIATE
IT GREATLY- LET ME COME BACK
AND SEE IF THEY'RE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS ARE SENATOR
LAYERED I SEE YOUR LIGHT IS ON.
YES I HAVE LISTENED TO MY
COLLEAGUES AND THEY DID NOT
DIFFERENTIATE ANY BETWEEN THE
THREE SO I WOULD MOVE THE
CONFIRMATION OF ALL THREE TO
THE- TO THE BOARD. AND THEN
THERE ARE GREAT CHOICES. THANK
YOU SENATOR WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR MADAM SECRETARY WE
CALL THE ROLL. REMOVE KAMLAGER.
I AM LONGER I LAYERED HI THERE
I BATES HI IF I ATKINS AYE
ATKINS FIVE ORDERS HERE IT IS
FOUR ZERO WE HAVE ONE ABSENCE
SO CONGRATULATIONS TO EACH OF
YOU- AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR SERVICE AND OF COURSE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
TODAY. CONGRATULATIONS THANK
YOU. I AM GOING TO GO BACK TO
ITEM ONE- GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES
REQUIRED TO APPEAR ON THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION AND OPEN THE
ROLE MADAM SECRETARY KAMLAGER I
AM LONGER HI. BATES RIGHT BATES
I FORTY ZERO FOUR TO ZERO THEY
WILL BE THRILLED TO KNOW THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN CONFIRMED LET ME
MOVE TO ITEM TWO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR AND ASK THAT YOU OPEN
THE ROLE. KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER
HI FOUR ZERO FOUR ZERO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH LET ME OPEN THE
ROLE ON ITEM THREE BILL
REFERRALS KAMLAGER. I LONGER
HIGH FOUR ZERO FOUR ZERO THANK
YOU WE ARE NOW GOING TO GO INTO
EXECUTIVE SESSION. AND I WILL
GIVE IT A MOMENT. THANK YOU ALL
HAVE A GOOD REST OF THE
AFTERNOON.